in a shocking twist
vice published an article where the left
is actually advocating for people to
take horse medicine in order to induce
abortions because with what's happening
in the roe v wade draft leak the world
has gone insane but you knew that the
world's been insane for some time i mean
donald trump was president and we all
know that uh it just it seems like we're
in some kind of tv show i guess it's the
joke right this the the writers for
season two they could not make things
more absurd and so quite literally vice
publishes an article talking about
misoprostol a horse drug for treating
horse ulcers that induces abortion in
women and they're like this is what you
can do
and and in the same breath in the same
paragraph they're like also like i've
vermectin which is also horse medicine
and i'm just like are you kidding me
you know what please do not ingest horse
medicine i don't care if the left tells
you to do it or whoever but uh we'll
talk about that we got the supreme court
justice uh um
chief justice john roberts has confirmed
that this leak is in fact an initial
draft and now there's conspiracies
running rampant about who leaked it the
left is claiming it was leaked by
conservatives
to force the other conservative justices
it was leaked by elito's camp so it
would force them to agree with them
because
initial drafts can change
and because this got leaked any change
to it now would insinuate public
pressure changed their ruling yeah i got
to be honest like literally all of the
news is just abortion and we've got a
lot there's protests the left is calling
for civil war i'm not even exaggerating
this like people are like tim talks
about civil war all the time they're
actually saying they want insurrection
revolution and they want to effing burn
it all down so i don't call it whatever
you want i guess but we've also got
other stuff that's in a similar vein too
we've got the story out of florida where
a family is suing because the school was
gender transitioning their child without
the parents knowing so joining us to
talk about that and many other things is
helena kirschner
hello i'm helena i write and i talk
primarily about trans issues from my
perspective as someone who
detransitioned and identified as trans
for about five years
so you were uh
biologically female
transitioned to
male or man or how would you what's the
proper terminology well i wouldn't say
that i transitioned to a man because i
was never a man but uh i did identify as
various flavors of non-binary and then
eventually as a boy and i took
testosterone for about a year and a half
oh wow and now you identify as a woman
yes i am a woman you are a woman yeah so
this is going to be interesting because
there is an overlap obviously with all
of these issues and i got to just point
it out because we often do you know when
reading these stories when we're
starting with the left advocating for
people taking horse medicine i'm just
like there's no principles behind what
they're advocating for it's like there's
no logic behind it so we'll get into all
that we also got sheamus sheamus good to
be here i'm the guy who makes freedom
tunes we uploaded a video today we'll be
uploading one on thursday and i just
want to mention the entire ivermectin
horse medicine thing was mostly a straw
man directed at the right but it's so
hilarious that like they couldn't even
maintain the don't take horse medicine
position that they totally fabricated to
try to dunk on us it's wonderful oh
there you go i'm gonna roll a hundred
sided die i don't know if you guys are
into superstition or if this is actually
like a magnet oh i rolled a four that's
my favorite number look it's almost very
close to a 100 very close yeah uh but i
am in crossland uh four is my favorite
number because when i used to play sorry
the board game if your first card you
drew was a four you got to go backwards
and then immediately got into the safe
zone
and i also like the color green
well okay now you know did you just call
me sheamus
that's what i get it's because
and then i just like wasn't thinking
what's up everybody let's get this
rolling well this is a very strong start
i'm excited for this evening with helena
it's gonna be awesome i'm excited to
hear what she has to say even though our
topic is not trans issues it will be
great look at that conversation you know
what i wanted to point out well firstly
it's helena
yeah
accents on the second part of the
warrior we were talking about this a
long time before the show yeah but
that's kind of a bummer because the song
from my chemical romance is helena
interesting
other thing i want to point out i'm
sorry if you guys are gonna be putting
numbers in the chat for me you know 20s
once you be a little more creative with
exactly what number you think i rolled
because it's 420. five percent chance
you're gonna get a one or a 20 like you
can roll 12 you can roll 13 you can roll
four it's okay for 20 69 if ian says
something good you got five dice to roll
and you were all four two six nine wait
four two zero six nine yeah you need a
d20 in there yahtzee
well i want to ask uh that's a difficult
role yes helena so what has the response
been to your work from transgender
actually
we should get in all this too yeah
because i don't want to just jump in
because we actually have a story okay if
you head over to timcast.com you can
actually see the the front page we have
right now is about a florida mother
suing school that secretly discussed
gender transition with her middle
schooler we'll get into that we'll get
to that later when we have you know i
want to give a dedicated segment where
you go deep in that stuff well i hope
the fbi is looking into her
oh yeah absolutely so before we get
started head over to tempgus.com become
a member help support our journalists in
the top right you'll see that sign up
button as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from the tim cast irl
podcast which is the show they go up
monday through thursday at 11 p.m so
we'll have a members only segment
tonight and you're also keeping our
journalists gainfully employed and we're
looking to hire more and we're also
going to be doing a bunch of fun culture
jamming as marketing probably one thing
per month which will be interesting and
probably
trigger some blue checkies
something like that and so we've got
just uh good good plans and i'm talking
with people that i don't want to say who
but people probably can figure out who
we're talking with um and we're going to
do some fun stuff so with your support
we're going to wrestle
rustle up some feathers
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's jump into this first story from
motherboard
vice.com anarchist collective shares
instructions to make diy abortion pills
diy medicine collectives are preparing
for the horrifying prospect that roe v
wade will be overturned
and in his image i guess that's
misoprostol i suppose the same with the
supreme court poised to overturn the
constitutional rights to abortion
constitutional right an anarchist
collective that makes diy medicine has
released detailed instructions for
making abortion pills the group has
previously released instructions for
making diy epipen and for making
uh what is that daraprim
daraprim
i don't know you're the fancy doctor
lydia what's that down yeah uh
yeah i've not seen that word the pill
that made farmer bro martin shkreli
famous
we talked about this a bit on the show
that like uh i think was tom with thomas
massey that
horse and no no sheep epinephrine
is like 30 bucks for 50 doses
and it's like the same dosage a person
gets and it's like oh but you can't take
she takes sheet medicine and i think
thomas is saying no it's literally the
same thing yeah but like an epipen is
500 bucks the insurance agencies are
colluding with the pharmaceutical
companies to spike the prices you pay
your insurance they pay the claim for
you they raise your insurance and then
you get this overpriced medicine well i
don't know about all that but what i do
know is in the article it says in the
video lawful explains that besides being
used to medically induce abortions
misoprostol is also used to treat ulcers
in horses
this makes misoprostol powder relatively
easy to acquire from veterinary
veterinary sources this is reminiscent
of vibramecten which is used to control
parasites and horses but also became a
favored but an effective covert
treatment among conspiracy theorists
ivermectin's uses use in horses made it
easier for humans to get without a
prescription
this is amazing lawfur explains in the
video how to dose misoprostol and how to
press in
it into pills using a scale corn syrup
powdered sugar a spray bottle and a
pollen press they explained that a three
dose regimen of misoprostol is 85
effective inducing in inducing abortion
if taken with mythopristone another
abortion pill that raises that rate
raises oh if taken with uh mifa preston
as i just said that the rate rises to 95
effectiveness through uh though raw
methopreston is harder to source so what
they're actually saying in this is that
people who are outraged over the
potential overturning of roe v wade have
told people to go to the vet to buy
horse medicine so they can have
abortions look if the worst case
scenario about the ivermectin horse
paste thing was that it didn't do
anything it didn't do anything there
were some stores where people getting
sick they would eat like a tube of horse
paste and you can't do that
but this actually hurts you this is like
a poison and another advocating for this
my friends well they've been advocating
for poisoning babies for quite a long
time look look
i know i say this quite a bit
when people go to you and they say
you know you're lying your sources of
news aren't real or whatever
people say to us how do i convince my
parents or my friends and my family that
you know the the news is fake
here
this
after everything they said about horse
medicine and joe rogan and this and the
smears they're now advocating for it
what more do you need to be like well
now they're saying take horse pills
i mean look if at this point someone can
see that and they think to themselves
well this one's okay it's like okay you
have no interest in being honest and
actually talking about what you believe
you have no principles
whatever man there's a couple layers to
this one is firstly it's not horse
medicine it's medicine that they put
into a horse pace to feed the horses
it's same with ivermectin it's a
medicine that was used in a horse
environment sometimes but it's not horse
medicine it's just medicine
secondly i talked about this last night
people are going to be inducing
miscarriages now
this is that's the problem with making
it illegal is people are going to keep
doing it and they're going to find
probably more dangerous and violent ways
to do it that's my concern anyway and
then this pops up yeah i mean i strongly
believe that fewer people are going to
do it no law is perfect you're never
going to prevent 100 of any crime you
try to deter people from committing but
ultimately making it illegal to have
abortions does prevent them and if it
didn't the left wouldn't really be upset
about all this you know to follow up on
that point i thought the same thing
about murder because i last night i was
thinking about our conversation and like
you know if murder was legal there would
be a lot more murder yeah so there is
something to making things illegal and
preventing the
the the proliferation of the activity
yeah i just don't like top down i don't
like saying now you now it's illegal so
no one can do it anymore like now it's
illegal to have guns so no one can 3d
print them anymore yeah right people are
going to still 3d print guns and you're
just going to create a criminal class no
i agree especially with gun control it's
complicated because people are finding
more and more ways to create them and
get them but ultimately part of the
reason why we oppose gun control is
because we know it would be harder to
get a firearm and fewer of us would be
able to if it were implemented so there
is some effectiveness
i mean gun control certainly is not
effective at lowering gun crime or
preventing homicide or anything like
that but it is
in some cases very effective at getting
guns out of the hands of law-abiding
citizens because the law can be
effective what do you think about all
this
i mean i'm i'm really conflicted on all
of the abortion stuff i mean i
i'm not entirely compelled by the
pro-life arguments but i also
i recognize that a lot of a lot of the
pro-choice or i guess pro-abortion
arguments are
just coming from very seemingly unwell
people and that there's just there's
something
anti-woman anti-human something that
just hates
motherhood about it and it just it
really skeeves me out so i'm just
watching all this stuff and and just
thinking like
how can we have a conversation about
this that isn't completely split between
these two i don't i don't so uh
the argument for over the past week or
so with elon musk is that the left you
post this meme showing the left moving
further and further left
and the right's kind of staying where it
is in the center then becomes right wing
because the left moves so far left and
the left keeps saying oh no that's not
true that's not happening
my response is
when i was a kid the right wanted to ban
abortion
as i grew up the left was saying safe
legal and rare a compromise no late-term
abortions most people in this country
even today disagree with abortions after
the first trimester that means second
trimester and third no abortions
i think the new york times reported this
that uh roe v wade actually pro
stops certain restrictions on abortion
in the second trimester which creates
this paradox but
we're gonna we get to get to that in a
second so the right today still wants to
ban abortion but now the left wants all
restrictions removed which is a huge
leap from where it was when i was
younger safe legal and rare meaning
in the first trimester if there are
certain issues so the issues that get
brought up frequently are ectopic
pregnancies
which i suppose the the argument sheamus
you and matt walsh brought up is that
you don't consider an abortion
pregnancy what does that mean it's the
principle of double effect so basically
there are certain medical procedures you
might have to perform on a sick woman
who happens to be pregnant that could
result in the death of the unborn child
and you perform that surgery to save her
life and if the unborn child dies that's
unfortunate but your intention is not to
go in there and kill the child it's an
unintended side effect of the operation
so that isn't considered an abortion i
think that's including by certain
pro-choice organizations by the way many
of them won't call it an abortion i know
webmd doesn't call out an abortion i
believe planned parenthood does not call
it so this is
this is the argument that's that's often
made from the left because i don't think
they're having conversations with
conservatives because i think talking to
matt walsh was particularly enlightening
he said if you have to term he
effectively said you can terminate a
pregnancy it doesn't mean you have to
kill the baby meaning at certain points
if you can save the baby's life why
wouldn't you do it
so it's like
there's an interesting question i think
for most pro-abortion people
you should we should ask if a woman is
pregnant in the second or third
trimester and the baby can safely be
removed ending the pregnancy but the
baby can also be saved should that be
mandated
yeah i think i mean i think they would
say no it's interesting you mentioned
that the left has become more extreme on
this issue and i completely agree but on
the other hand i think they've really
just become more consistent to their
their base principle here on the right
the argument was that this is a human
life and so it has to be protected from
conception until natural death and on
the side of the left it was basically
the argument that like either we don't
know if this is a human life or it
alt-right isn't a human life and in that
case it doesn't make sense to restrict
it at all so we were we were talking a
little bit before the show and helena
was saying you were saying that you know
you're not you don't have a really
strong position on this
i don't i don't i'm sorry no you don't
have to because i actually i i kind of
agree with you
there's a uh i don't have i don't have a
particularly strong position on this
because it's it's almost an impossible
moral question and i keep looking to the
left for moral arguments which they
don't have
they they and so i'm like okay i don't
know you know i've heard the argument
meet him i've heard the arguments from
the right and they're static like here's
the argument life begins at conception
life you know life has rights the
government has to protect the rights of
the living you have two people and i'm
like there's a really interesting
ethical conundrum in here when we're
talking about the rights of two people
sharing one body in one bloodstream and
then look to the left and they say
things like
life doesn't begin until first breath
that's that's a quote from the bible i
think well no no it's not from the bible
there are certain people who have tried
to argue that because um adam takes or
god breathes life into adam in the old
testament that that means that scripture
is saying life does not begin until the
first breath but that's an unbelievable
reach and
the prohibition on abortion is one of
the earliest christian teachings i mean
it states all the way back to the first
century so it's just not true either way
i'm not entirely sure um
what the left does want
so my position and my family has always
been like we talk about all the time is
it's safe legal and rare that's the
famous
saying even tulsi gabbard was saying it
and it's like
there should be restrictions and so my
position is not particularly strong i
really don't know and i don't understand
why so many people are screaming the top
of their lungs about this because
abortion wasn't even banned it's just
going to a state-level thing so it's
like okay i don't know petition your
state vote for your local reps or if
you're the majority of democrats and you
live in a blue state you have nothing to
worry about i think some of it is just
sort of your classic typical histrionic
leftist behavior every time something
goes wrong for them in politics they end
up throwing a tantrum and will even burn
down cities attack people commit acts of
violence another part of it is i think
there are some number of people whose
consciences are genuinely bothered
because either they've had an abortion
or they've helped someone participate
you know they've participated in helping
someone procure an abortion and they
haven't really reconciled with the
wrongness of that and so anything that
reminds them that some people don't
approve of that behavior really sends
them off the edge i want to pull up this
poll from civics
which party is more concerned with
people like you
i chose the 18 to 34 demographic and you
can see
41 say democrats 30 percent say neither
25 say republicans and i probably fall
in that neither camp and i assume most
people watching do
that's why
a lot of the arguments coming from the
democrats on this issue don't make sense
because they lump the neither and the
republican groups together yeah even
though like the neither side is like
well i guess i'll vote for a republican
because the democrats are nuts but i
don't like republicans at all yeah well
and it's also the case that for me i'm
very conservative but i don't really
feel the republican party has like my
best interests in mind as a person
either and i think most republicans
don't feel that way it's it's actually
very interesting that 41 percent uh say
they think the democratic party has
their interests and minds be in mind
because what that says to me is
democrats are just much more likely to
fall in lockstep with the party line and
say oh the politician who told me they
have my best interest in mine has my
best interest in mind i had a
conversation with stephen crowder and he
asked me about my stance on abortion and
then i was like i've my family you know
i grew up we were we were pro-choice
these are the arguments we heard it was
always about there being some reasonable
restrictions
but now the issue i have i guess is like
you know that what was that woman's name
michelle wolf is that the comedian yeah
saluting to abortion saying everyone
gets abortions lena dunham saying she
wished she had one and i'm like that
doesn't represent me or my family and my
community at all
and so which party do i vote for the
republicans want to ban it outright i'm
like okay well i don't know if i agree
with that the democrats want zero
restrictions
and they literally have people who are
like at the point of birth the baby can
be killed they have it was northam i
think right in virginia where he said
the baby will be delivered and made
comfortable and then the mother and the
doctor will have a conversation on what
to do next and i was like what what yeah
i was like who am i voting for right now
so when we say politically homeless you
know i don't care if these zealot cult
people are like you're a republican i'm
like sure i guess
cause like not
snipping the spinal cord of a baby at
nine months right as it's being born if
i have a choice between not doing that
and doing that i'd be like i guess i'm
voting republican you know yeah can i
just mention one more thing before we
jump into this i think it goes even
deeper than that because obviously you
and i disagree on this i don't believe
there should be any exception abortion
should be completely illegal however
it's not just that the democratic party
is even necessarily saying abortion up
until the last second of pregnancy in a
number of states as you mentioned there
have been discussions about even
allowing the child to die after the
abortion has failed but on top of that
our you know quote unquote very catholic
president joe biden
has talked about appealing the hyde
amendment and the height amendment
prevents federal funding from paying for
abortions so basically the position of
the left is that yes taxpayers should be
funding this
i want to pull up that video
like the most extreme possible position
i don't trust a lot of these news so i'm
going to try and find this video
oh oh we have reuters
have the video i'm surprised i want to
make sure i play this
so a meme shared by over 70 000 people
are they gonna play the full video
oh i can't you can't wait hold on here
we go
okay this is 50 minutes long maybe i'll
just have to try and find it also and
can i ask you we obviously we're just
having a conversation on which political
party people feels represents them like
where do you land there do you feel
either partying against you or
no i i really don't i just i feel very
cynically about both um i think the
democrats are wrong for obvious reasons
but then the republicans are just kind
of
putting up a fake opposition to that and
then siphoning off money from all their
donors and and then obviously not really
putting up any resistance to it
considering the last few decades yeah
they both democrats and republicans do
this it's all just part of the same
machine it's just barack obama
so this i i have to fact check me on
this one but i'm pretty sure barack
obama campaigned on codifying roe v wade
once the they had the presidency the
house and the senate and then once he
gets elected he's like well it's not a
top concern for me so i'm not going to
do it we heard this from marjorie taylor
green
that i think was margaret taylor green
and thomas massey that even the
republicans will be like we don't really
want to ban obamacare because we need
the wedge issue so they purposefully
tried was that thomas massey i think i
don't think i remember who it was i
don't know oh no no no was the other guy
it was the other freedom caucus guy we
had on what was his name
older guy freedom caucus anyway he was
saying that they go they go to him and
they're like we have the vote to end
obamacare but don't do it because we
need to rally up our base you know we
don't want to lose the issue wow i'm
going to play this for you from vox all
right let's listen to this exception
there was a very contentious committee
hearing yesterday when fairfax county
delegate kathy tran made her case for
lifting restrictions on third trimester
abortions as well as other restrictions
now in place and she was pressed by a
republican delegate about whether her
bill would permit an abortion even as a
woman is essentially dilating ready to
give birth and she answered
that it would permit an abortion at that
stage of labor do you support her
measure and explain her answer yeah you
know i wasn't there uh julie and i i
certainly can't
speak for uh delegate tran but um i will
tell you one uh first thing i would say
this is why decisions such as this
should be made by providers uh
physicians uh and uh the uh
mothers uh and fathers that that are
involved um there are you know when we
talk about third trimester abortions
these are done uh with the consent of
obviously the the mother with the
consent
of the physicians more than one
physician by the way um and it's done in
cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non-viable so in this particular example
if a mother is in labor i can tell you
exactly what would happen
the infant would be delivered
the infant would be kept comfortable uh
the infant would be resuscitated if
that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so i think
this was really blown out of proportion
uh but again
so not a proportion
of what he's talking about deformities
and non-viable fetuses but he said it
would be resuscitated and then a
discussion would happen in the context
of an abortion it sounds a lot like to
me like he was saying a living baby
would be kept comfortable and
resuscitated and then we discuss whether
we kill it
and also maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm crazy
about that maybe that's that is the most
straightforward reading of what he just
said and also when he talks about wait
wait i'm sorry i'm sorry i just i just
even outside of that psychotic context
the woman asking the question is talking
about
third trimester abortions where the baby
the woman is dilating and the baby is
about to be born and there would be no
restrictions
and he's like yeah right okay well you
see the thing is
stop right there that in and of itself
to me is just beyond psychosis yeah he
gave the most i'm not a biologist answer
ever to that question he's like well
yeah it's betraying the doctor and the
woman it's like what killing a baby
he mentioned deformities and
non-viability non-viability i imagine
means that the baby's not going to
survive is that what that means
he specifically said it's about or at
least he thinks it's about deformities
and non-viability so if a deformed child
is born
i just don't see why that would be a
reason of whether or not you could kill
it i ju that
either kill it or don't but don't it's
not about like i mean i guess if the
deformity is so horrific like it's born
with one lung
helena as somebody who doesn't have a
very strong opinion based on what you
just heard what do you think
i mean i i think that's
it's obviously very wrong to kill a
living baby like don't don't get me
wrong and i think like a lot of people
they'll argue that this is just
it's an extreme version of like a
pro-choice stance but most women who are
getting abortions like aren't you know
killing their living babies but then i
think to myself well then what does it
say about someone like him uh even if he
does have that more moderate stance on
abortion for i guess normal women
what does it say about his logic and his
reasoning more moderate
well i mean i don't know it's like
people will say
i'm not saying that
and again i don't agree like i'm against
abortion in all cases but i believe what
she's saying is
he he's representing arguably the more
common position on abortion but then
he's also representing this a very
uncommon yeah and people say that this
isn't a representation of like the
average pro-choice person but if the
average pro-choice person would defend
this what does that say about like their
their ideology in general yeah that's a
very good point
he was the governor at the time well and
shouldn't if if this didn't represent
pro-choice or shouldn't they be out
there decrying it how could you say this
how could you make our movement look so
horrible by smearing us in this way he
really that was word salad what he put
out there like i didn't even catch the
deformity part until today and i've
heard him say that before and that's
that's like
that's why people aren't speaking about
it because they don't understand what he
said reuters like missing context
i'm like dude we all heard what he said
man
i like how that is just such a magic
phrase you can slap that on everything
partly false
partly false
northrom was not supporting infanticide
yo he literally said the baby would be
resuscitated in the discussion would
ensue in the context of abortion what do
you have been talking about what are
they going to discuss but gender why
didn't he say outright
i think that if a woman is dilating you
should not be able to kill the baby at
that point is it hard to say
that's it's just insane it's hard for
him to say though but i think part of
why it's hard for him to say is because
he knows that the radical left has an
immense amount of power in the
democratic party he's a coward who
doesn't want to stand for human life and
he's aware that he will destroy his
career as a member of the democratic
party if he says anything about any kind
of abortion
i think he honestly
supports the
the the activity of
killing a fully developed human baby
that is just born that has a deformity
like a serious deformity could be true
as well yeah i mean that's certainly
what he said that's absolutely what he
said yeah
yeah
yeah i mean you really got to strip
apart deformity because you could have
like your finger could be bent and that
you're considered deformed as a child
because one finger is bent like that's
not a reason to abort a kid well and i
agree with what you said earlier that
there i mean whether someone is deformed
or not that's not a reason to kill
somebody some deformities are so
horrific that you might actually save
the child some suffering i know i'm
being it's an extreme example but like
you know severe brain damage i don't
know man but then you ask that that
severely brain damaged person when
they're 30 or 40 like are you glad
you're alive but like what kind of
destruction are they got not destruction
overt destruction but what kind of like
you know sucking away of resources are
severely deformed people on society
when i say deformed it's a very vague
statement because it's not about like
autism that i'm not talking about that
kind of thing and even if i don't even
think that adds it to the formula well
can i i just want to mention one thing
um because this is obviously a much
bigger discussion i just want to
sort of say this
to think about you mentioned them
consuming resources but what if it's the
case that
resources are there for humans and not
the other way around
the purpose of this is very um
homo superior i don't like it i don't
think that things are here for us i
think we just happen to be here and at
the top of the food chain but if we're
talking about resources like what if it
is the case that human life is
intrinsically valuable and
the reason resources are valuable is
because they help us they help keep us
alive so to say it's better off if this
person is dead because that'll conserve
resources is self-defeating because the
purpose of the resource is to keep a
person alive only because if people have
unlimited food they grow exponentially
and overcrowd and destroy the system
that they're like the deer population
overeats you know you and so there's
this built-in kind of like starvation
method into humanity that keeps us from
overgrowing almost it seems like i think
i think we need to paul the audience if
you disagree with ian hit the like
button
if you did and if you agree with sheamus
hit the like button yes um
smash that like button
i think the problem with that is that's
malthusianism right and that thinking
has been debunked by basically all of
the historical analyses so as the world
population has increased poverty in
global poverty has decreased
significantly as more people have
existed there's been less poverty there
have been more resources getting a
little wide on the conversation let's
make one more point before we move on
one of the deformities uh that people
refer to
is or one of the we'll call it issues
that the left often refers to as to why
abortions should be allowed as down
syndrome
and there was uh there's a very famous
video of a man with down syndrome i
think he's testifying before congress
right saying that they would have me
killed why it's like these people are
alive they're functioning they they are
functioning human beings but it's just
because the traits they have are
undesirable people want them terminated
before they could be alive but the
people who are alive are happy people i
get it like humans are we want to be
more than animals but we're animals and
we're just smart animals and like
animals will destroy their young if
they're not healthy often
other non-human animals like it's just
they're gonna hold back the pack you
can't you can't risk everyone else's
existence because of one small feeble
child and so they'll destroy it at birth
you know but our society is not
crumbling because we're allowing
disabled people to live our society is
crumbling because we don't care enough
for one another and we view other human
beings as objects in that i don't think
it's crumbling i mean i i guess it's
just a way of looking at it
i think the united states
i mean there's a lot of tremendous
victories that the
liberty or right whatever you want to
call it has has achieved recently like
elon musk buying twitter
but i think the leak of the roe v wade
initial draft shows for the first time
in history this happened like yeah our
institutions are basically on fire 20th
century institutions man there are 18th
century institutions that we're using
it's time to pull up this story
in a tweet from stephen marsh we've had
on the show he says honestly guys when a
marriage gets like this you sit the kids
down and tell them it's over and you
figure out how to separate with as
little pain and suffering as possible
he links to his article from the
guardian in which he makes a very
important point
he writes
civil wars don't always begin with
gunfire sometimes civil wars begin with
learned arguments in april 1861
confederate forces shot on fort sumter
but at the time even jefferson davis the
confederate president had doubts about
whether the event mattered all that much
it was he claimed quote either the
beginning of a fearful
war or the end of a political contest he
could not say which during the decades
that preceded the assault on fort sumter
complex legal and political fissures had
been working their way through the
united states slowly rendering the
country ungovernable and opening the
path to mass violence yo i just got to
say that uh civil war is coming
from fox news liberals call for
revolution in response to leaked scotus
roe v wade opinion it's not just
liberals there's one guy he's running
for a.g in florida that's my i believe
that's who this guy is it's time for a
revolution these are blue check verified
twitter users taking donations through
act blue advocating for
insurrection yeah i'll hold my breath
and waiting for the may 2nd commission
so i also want to give one quick shout
out to this uh uh this tweet from
madison cawthorne who said
because of donald j trump roe v wade
will be overturned because if you went
10 years of the past and started telling
people that they would call in a 5150
which for those that aren't familiar is
involuntary commitment to a
hospital for mental issues
donald trump
he's gonna be president and then roe v
wade is gonna be overturned they're like
okay dude calm down i think you're
losing it that's not gonna happen and
then it did
and here here we are and it's quite
amazing but uh now we have this story
from fox check us out we have other
people maria shriver saying say you want
a revolution well you have one here
right now this person says waking up to
another right for my body being
threatened in 2022 if they want a
revolution they are going to get one
it's not a revolution it's a civil war
the republican position right now is red
states get to choose whether they have
abortions or not and so do blue states
the democrat position is the entire
country should have to allow abortion
one is absolutist one is a compromise
i'll say it again the republicans are
compromising blue states are allowed to
have abortions red states don't and the
democrats are saying no we don't care
you have to have abortions okay that's
not a revolution when you come out and
you say we're gonna force you to have
these laws that's called a civil war
that is not a moral statement about who
is right or wrong it is a fact statement
about what a civil war is so hey civil
war guys no if there is one it's going
to be global that's the problem and the
u.s is going to get beat like a young
i'm not going deeper on that and it'll
be corporations will be involved as well
so no not civil war i i think
when we're talking about why why people
want the federal government to preserve
abortion rights is because if you're in
a red state or you say you're in a blue
state and then roe v wade gets
overturned and your governor's like
don't worry you can still be here you
set up a family thousands hundreds of
thousands of people move there they live
there they have lives they have
businesses they set up families then a
new governor gets in is like yeah you
can't have abortions here anymore like
why would one person get to make that
decision
that's why it's federally instantiated i
believe is that then why would one
person get to make the decision to allow
it that's another question because
they're making a decision to allow all
those unborn children to die this is
funny the people the left keeps saying
men should not be regulating women's
bodies and then everyone keeps posting a
picture of the supreme court in 1973
which is all men well and also our you
know the um oh my gosh i'm blanking on
her name she was just uh
dominated by biden for tanji yes that's
right she could not answer the question
of what a woman is so what are they
saying when they're talking about men
regulating women's bodies i just this is
the point you know with the first story
about the horse medicine for abortion
it's like dude
they they're saying there's a guy a
picture of a guy in front of the supreme
court or whatever holding a sign saying
men should not be regulating women's
bodies or something like something like
if you uh uh
like it was something about like men i
don't know i know what it said it said
if men could get pregnant then abortion
would be enshrined or whatever and it's
like okay hold on i'm confused now
because y'all are telling me that men
could get pregnant for a long time yeah
now you're telling me that they can't so
this is like an affront i'm just
confused at this point i think this
conflict is going to be really
interesting because
it's not
liberal versus conservative
it is
cult
amoral versus
logic i guess
that's one way to put it i'm like oh god
oh no i would just like to ask you
you i'm not sure you uh i'm not sure
which uh you know social circles you're
running and now i'm sure they've changed
since you've de-transitioned but i'm
sort of curious what the people around
you have to say about all this and also
the not to put you two on the spot but
the prospect of a civil war in your
opinion
you're 23 tell us he's like do you think
which side will you be on no but i am
curious with how the people around you
been responding to it that's part of why
i'm so conflicted because i do
i guess
talk to a lot of women who i do highly
respect i think they're intelligent i
think that they are moral people they're
not you know some of these crazy people
that you see in the most extreme cases
and they really really really care about
abortion and
obviously you know abortion being as
accessible as possible and then i'm just
kind of sitting there thinking like well
hey i don't feel that strongly about it
something about it makes me very
uncomfortable and you know
i get
confused thinking about all of these
different like extreme possibilities of
what could happen because i'm still just
trying to like slow down and think about
okay well is it a human life or not and
i i don't see the argument for why it's
not a human life and then if it is a
human life then how is ending it okay
like that i'm kind of like stuck there
so it's not that well it sounds like
hold on i have an important question
in in your uh life experience going
through transition and detransition do
you feel that you were lied to by
elements of the left
uh yes absolutely and that's i'm i'm
highly skeptical of that and even when
that uh ralph northam guy
says oh it's between a woman and her
doctor i hear that exact same thing said
about the trans kids it's about the kids
and their doctor and i know that sets
off alarm bells in my head that like
this person's a liar and then so that's
basically my my follow-up question is do
you think that they may be lying to you
about abortion absolutely i i know for a
fact that they are this is this is the
big issue that that i personally face
because uh
you know i mean
traditionally liberal my whole life but
now the problem is oh i love doing this
you ready trayvon martin's story was a
lie
jesse smallett was a lie covington kids
was a like how written house was a lie
russian gate was a lie ukraine ukraine
gate was a lie ahmed arby's story was a
lie come on guys what else
the ghost of um ghost of kiev that was a
lie also alive uh so all of these
stories keep turning out to be false and
then i'm supposed to believe anything
these people say and i'm just like dude
i don't know man
i have i don't i just don't believe you
i don't believe any of them no no no no
hold on all says i really don't respect
or like lindsey graham or mitch
mcconnell or kevin mccarthy exactly i
don't think those people are honest
either i don't think they're telling me
the truth like when they share their
arguments i'm like you're a liar too so
it's just it's hard they don't they
don't they don't want i don't think the
republicans actually want um abortion be
banned
because just like the democrats they
need the wedge issue i think for some
number of them they recognize that to
some percentage of the population they
would kind of become politically
irrelevant if abortion was illegal so
some of them probably cynically exploit
the issue but i am curious to to ask you
when you were in the process of
i guess they would call it transitioning
was there anyone in your life who tried
to warn you against it or tried to stop
you from going down that path
um the only person really would be my
parents but they
i just don't think they really knew how
to handle it i mean how does anyone know
how to handle that yeah um but yeah they
they reacted very emotionally and i
think that that just furthered the
schism between us and just sent me like
it it literally you know ruined our
relationship for like a year we didn't
even talk um so that was pretty much the
only person but everyone else including
at my school it was all like yeah you're
a boy
do you wish that there had been more
people in your life at that time who
would stand up for you and your dignity
and protect you from that definitely
what was that well i think that you can
be that voice for the unborn
because i think you recognize that it is
a life and it does begin at conception
and i think you could do a lot of good
in protecting the innocent in a way that
you weren't protected when you needed
someone so i think everything a really
big portion of this argument that is
left out when it comes to the left one
of the things i heard is what happens if
the um the placenta breaks early on in
the pregnancy and it's terminal for the
baby and the woman republicans wouldn't
allow an abortion in the circumstance
sheamus yes if that something like that
happened wait could you repeat the
question so someone posted i was like on
twitter and they said
in the instance where a woman is like in
the second trimester and the placenta
breaks it's ruptured and the baby and
the mother will both die unless the baby
is removed they say republicans would
not allow that so again my answer is you
perform whatever surgery is necessary to
save the mother without the intent to
kill the child or without directly
harming the child and if the child dies
as an unfortunate side effect of that
that happens but that's not the same as
an abortion so i think that's an
important semantic component that is
overlooked that when at least you and
matt walsh were describing it you you're
talking about abortion as
specifically and only the intentional
act of killing the baby yeah when you go
in there now i think there could be an
argument to be made that someone could
behave recklessly and kill a child and
be morally culpable for that as well but
yeah an abortion is the direct
intentional murder of an unborn no no
involuntary abortion that's called
miscarriage
abortions yes spontaneous abortion is a
medical term that is sometimes used
spontaneous abortion is a medical or not
that sometimes you used to describe it
we're not talking about we're not
talking about the dictionary we're
talking about what is sheamus and matt
walsh's intent in their language
so i can understand
where he's coming from in terms of law
because i don't think it's reasonable if
a woman is like i have a medical issue
with my pregnancy and we're both going
to die it does not make sense to me that
a conservative would be like well then
you have to that no that's why the woman
has the right to carry a weapon a second
amendment to protect yourself right well
no the point i'm making is
in talking with seamus and matt as well
as many other pro-life people
there's i've not encountered a
circumstance where a pro-lifer has said
the woman and the baby should both die
if they have to yeah but i'm okay so if
we're going to make
abortion does that include miscarriages
like
like involuntary abortions are they just
talking about volunteers is it a stroke
murder yeah
if you use the cia stroke gun then maybe
but i don't know sure if it's an induced
stroke if if somebody i i think this is
a silly argument that i've heard quite a
bit and it's just like but what about a
miscarriage and i'm like yeah sometimes
people die we don't you don't go to
prison if you're like a guy has a heart
attack they don't go well time to arrest
somebody yeah it's like what is a
voluntary involuntary is what it comes
down to
and then their people will opt you skate
that obviously and make it seem
involuntary can we have uh
i'd like to i'd like to move over to a
social component i just want to mention
one more thing i think there are
instances where the leftover like i have
read um petitions signed by like
literally hundreds of doctors that have
said there's no such thing as a
medically necessitated abortion there
are instances where surgery might need
to be performed that like poses a risk
to the life of the unborn child but
there's no such thing as an insult but
you have to go in and you have to kill
the child and this is important because
what you're saying is
you are not referring to the intentional
act of killing the baby for the sake of
removing it you're saying
in the instance where a mother is
has a medical issue
the intention isn't to kill the baby but
the baby might die because of it yeah
were you always like anti-abortion
growing up my whole life i've been
anti-abortion in fact there was a period
of time in my late teens where i really
didn't take my faith seriously and i
think for all intents and purposes i
could probably be described as atheistic
and at no point during that
period in my life did i ever think it
was okay to kill an unborn child i just
couldn't wrap my head around that being
accepted well let me ask you this a
woman is
20 weeks pregnant
and something occurs where the doctor is
like
if we do not terminate this pregnancy
the mother will die
i want to be very careful about this
because as i've said i've i mean i've
read literature from doctors and i've
spoken to doctors who have said that
this kind of thing doesn't happen
again there are instances where surgery
could pose a risk to the life of them
instead of talking about if we're
talking about like hold on
instead of trying to say it doesn't
happen so i can't answer it let's just
hypothetically
i think i've laid out my principles
right if if there is a surgery that will
save the mother's life but it poses a
risk to the life of a child and that's
the only thing absolute death
like
20 weeks you will die unless this
pregnancy has ended right now get a
second opinion
what would three doctors tell you that
now right great three doctors all say
yeah the uh the baby is killing you
because of you know this medical issue
yeah if it's the case that the the
mother will die i think you you save her
and you also do everything you can to
save the baby but not intentionally kill
the baby yes yeah absolutely and still
do everything you can to save the baby
and the mother what if the surgery is
much safer if you kill the baby and
remove it as opposed to a much more
risky procedure where you have you can
try and preserve the baby and maybe the
woman will live uh again i mean we're
getting so that just doesn't exist in my
opinion you destroy the fetus to give
the woman the best chance of survival
but that doesn't mean that scenario
doesn't exist that's like what if you
have to shoot a power cable oh man yeah
it could be mine
shame
airing on the side of do whatever the
the most likely thing for the mother of
survival whether that means if it means
that she's got a 10 percent chance less
if you go for the say ah that's how i
don't know you know it's funny though
how many stories have you heard where a
mother who has cancer for goes chemo to
save the life of her baby it has
happened
for a while it happens a lot there's a
it was a really famous story that was
only i think a year ago where a woman
raised a bunch of money she said she had
cancer and they said you need to go on
chemo now or you'll die
it'll also kill your baby and she was
like nope baby lives i'll die i always
hate that when doctors are like if you
don't do this then this dude who art
what kind of authority do you think you
are yeah you went to med school good job
well i mean you can choose to trust your
doctor
let's let's jump over to the social
components here because we've got some
funny stuff to talk about in this reddit
post from two x chromosomes which is
transphobic by the way very transparent
right just cancelled a first date this
week because i can't emotionally handle
more men in my life after all of this
after the scotus news the idea of having
to laugh at some dude's jokes and listen
to him ramble on about his life and
possibly kiss and have sex with him
knowing he has all the rights in the
world and i don't i just can't i don't
have the emotional energy to even fake a
smile i don't know when i will this was
one of the highest rated posts on the
two x chromosomes
uh
subreddit
and um yo this is some kind of
borderline or that's insane
well actually let's ask the both of the
ladies in the room do you ever feel like
guys are walking around like i have all
of these
laugh at you yeah and your subject agent
what is this do you do you ever feel
this way as women that men are walking
around going i just don't understand how
the man has the right to have an
abortion when men
don't get pregnant well hold on wait
wait men but hold on i was told men can
get pregnant that's true that's very
true this is really interesting
two x chromosomes has a pride flag right
here in there in the subreddit you can
see when you pull it up
so uh
you can see right here they have the
pride flag as like part of the colors
but they're saying more men in my life
have all the rights but what about a
pregnant man a pregnant man would not
have the right to an abortion by their
logic and standards
i don't think they have any logic no i
think it is just it's like it's it's
like you know what i call it it's fire
it's chaotic it expands
it's in and then it consumes
this makes this
propaganda that just is making people
crazy like i genuinely just i i don't
feel this strongly about it because i
don't feel that pregnancy would be the
absolute worst thing that could ever
happen to me that would end my life and
so i need to like have this much fear
that controls me about it if you hear
that states you don't live in
may restrict abortion in a few months
and then you look at some random man and
you're like i just can't you
you and your rights
get out of my sight it's just
you're not you're you've lost it yeah
completely something is wrong it's
absurd well it's also again men it's not
as if men have the right to go i mean i
guess the male abortion doctors do but i
think you know they should be stripped
of that right as well not now they don't
right once abortion is illegal so i have
no idea we i'm talking about can we give
a collective shout out to all of the
women who do this every time they say
it's time to stop having sex with men
and that's just like strata that's the
play but they're thinking they think
that it's like some punishment and all
the conservatives are like based yeah i
know it's like you know what you know
what because of these far-right
conservatives i'm just i'm not gonna
have sex with a man until her values are
similar enough to have a child together
and he commits to me for life and it's
like this yeah that's good this was
actually a post i saw it was a woman
saying ladies it's time for a sex strike
and it was like explain to the men that
it's too risky now that because they
could get pregnant and that means having
a baby they can't risk having sex with a
man and it's just like that's the
conservative argument like you're
literally making the conservative
argument for like
not having sex out of wedlock i think
but what you're ignoring tim is they're
actually talking about creating this
institution where the woman only has sex
with one man she trusts to raise a child
with her in case she does get pregnant
and they're not allowed to leave each
other so i think that's like a new
original interesting idea yo you know it
was one of the craziest things i was
reading about that there were lesbians
who became straight during coveted
lockdown
did you you don't see those stories
there was one it was like i think maybe
vice published it where it was a woman
she was like i'm a lesbian but i was
quarantined with my roommate who's male
and we started dating and like hooking
up and then she was like she changed
like something
well it i don't know and the same it's
interesting because in the same way that
we are not allowed to acknowledge the
existence of de-transitioners such as
yourself you're also not allowed to
acknowledge the existence of people who
no longer identify as homosexual
i think you got this is it from slate
yeah my identity is less important than
my intimacy yes it's from april 10th
2020. a quarantine fling with my
roommate has me questioning my sexuality
so i think this was uh
yeah it's like running her hands through
his chest hair she hasn't hooked up with
a man in three years but then she got
locked down with him and her identity
didn't matter anymore and i'm like it's
a confusing article to me because
sexual and identity are different to
these people i didn't i didn't know that
i don't know how much that is like an
actual lesbian turning straight because
of the pandemic and how much of it is
just like the queer ideology about what
a lesbian actually is
like i think that there's a lot of
people who are involved in these
communities and they call themselves gay
or they call themselves a lesbian but
it's like they're thinking of it more
from like a gender identity perspective
as opposed to like actually growing up
being like a homosexual person that's
interesting so i would ask you is
someone who did detransition do you
uh like reject the idea of
transgenderism altogether or do you just
believe that was something that didn't
work for you
um yeah i reject the whole category of
trans trans people i don't think that
that's a meaningful
cat because it's like can we get a
definition of that please what is a
trans person and how is that different
from a person who
identifies as trans and then no longer
identifies as trans yeah and that's a
very good point and not only do they not
have a definition for that but they've
dispensed with important definitions for
things like woman or man so it like
causes the system to become incoherent
but i'm curious as someone who you know
spent you said five years as transgender
what
what made you see
that this was not legitimate i start
from the beginning
how did how did you come to
be trans and then how did you come to
not be
yeah so it wasn't like i just woke up
one day and went from being
myself to wanting to be a boy um so
growing up i never i wasn't like super
masculine or anything i was never even
really like a tomboy i feel like i had
like a good even mix of like girl
typical boy typical interests and stuff
um so it really started for me when i
started using the internet a lot
for me it was tumblr that i started
using the most and on tumblr
there is a strong emphasis on like
social justice ideology and so in order
to participate in those communities you
have to adopt a lot of those beliefs so
i kind of adopted those like radical
progressive beliefs about gender and and
race and everything honestly um and in
that environment it's it's highly
encouraged to like experiment with your
gender identity like you see all of
these
messages that are just like oh well if
you don't like your body that's a sign
that you're trans or if you
read certain kinds of fan fiction that's
a sign that you're trans and you should
change your pronouns you should cut your
hair and just see how it feels and then
every time you do that you cut your hair
to see how it feels or you change your
pronouns then everybody comes and like
lavishes positive attention on you so i
think it was like
yeah yeah but it's for me in my case i
know that there are legitimate cases of
grooming where adults actually i mean
there are trans activists who brag about
how many minors they've sent hormones to
through the mail um so that that
definitely is a thing that happens but
for me it was mostly like just other
teenagers who were going through i don't
know loneliness depression um eating
disorders are also really common who
were just kind of all latching on to
this idea that they're born in the wrong
body or they're they're meant to be
someone else and they can just discover
that and then they can bring that into
the real world that must feel very
difficult you know to think that you are
not actually yourself or you are not
actually the person whose body that you
occupy
um i would say it's very easy for
someone who's disconnected from reality
and doesn't have a lot of ties to like
the real physical world like for context
in my adolescence i was one of those
kids who like i didn't really play any
sports i didn't have a lot of friends in
real life i mainly just kind of was
online doing creative things like
writing and doing art and talking to
other people online so i think it's easy
to get lost in
like especially as a creative person you
can get lost in these ideas about who
you are and what you can become
well i i just want to clarify by
difficult i don't necessarily mean um
it's it's difficult to pull off or do
i'm saying it sounds like it would be
painful though to to feel as though you
had not matched what you were meant to
be it's possible i'm off base here yeah
i think the feelings that brought me to
search for that were painful so i was
like i had a ton of self-esteem issues i
had depression
and all this kind of stuff so that was
incredibly painful but the idea that
you know the source of all that pain was
that i was meant to be another gender
and that i can
transition it'll fix everything that
wasn't painful interesting
can i just ask you mentioned i just got
asked that you mentioned fan fictions
what were people saying that fan fiction
said about your gender identity
yes so um
one thing on tumblr that is uh very very
popular it's not fringe at all it's very
popular is like male male fan fiction
it's like gay fan fiction
um and so people will say that oh if
you're a girl and you read gay
fanfiction that is like the number one
sign that you're actually a boy inside
yeah how old were you when you first got
into the um tumblr 13 13. and so how did
you come to
change and move away from all of that so
it actually took bringing that into the
real world by you know actually
trying to
look like a boy and like act like a boy
and be in like male spaces using the
men's restroom i actually did that um
it was just like holy crap like this is
not
right for me at all you were taking
testosterone for a year yeah and a half
yeah i was taking testosterone for a
year and a half and another
uh part of it that made me really uh
regret it and realize that it was a
mistake is the fact that the
testosterone had extremely negative
effects on me like what um so for me it
was mostly psychological i wasn't on it
for long enough for it to have like any
long-term physical effects but um
just it really destabilized me and
another piece of context is that the
people who prescribed me it prescribed
me four times the dosage that i should
have started on
um and that's a whole other story we can
get into if you want
yeah yeah um so basically i i got my
testosterone from planned parenthood and
it was just one appointment i walk in um
they talked to me for like 20 minutes
and then i sit down with a nurse
practitioner and she says okay we're
gonna start you on like 25 milligrams
and then i say to her well i think that
i need more because my hips are big so i
think i have extra estrogen and i'm
gonna need more testosterone to look
like a boy and she did not push back on
that whatsoever and she just asked me
like okay well how high would you like
to go and then i said what's the highest
we can do and she said okay we'll start
you on 100 milligrams and then wow yeah
i just got sent out
interesting bad people it turns out yeah
was it like physical any physical nausea
or anything
um no
did you want to fight people yes that
was the thing like i literally was just
completely transformed into like a
different person like um the way i
describe it is like
my
i stopped having a wide spectrum of
emotion and instead of like okay
something happens and it makes me feel
abandoned so that i'm nervous so then
i'm sad so then i cry
i would just go straight from like point
a to point i'm gonna anger now you know
punch somebody a guy
always sounds right i was not able to
like crazy yeah
tim and i had a moment we're like yes
it's like you're a dude and you're like
working in the backyard and you're like
trying to hammer a nail and then you hit
the nail and the nail drops you get
angry
yes you're skateboarding you're trying
to do a trick you miss it's angry ah you
walk into the kitchen to get a sandwich
there's no more roast beef
and like you're punching things that but
imagine you're actually a neurotic 18
year old girl oh my god oh you had it
all
that's amazing
i remember it's horrible there was a
simpsons joke about that where ralph or
something was taking no no it was martin
he was like they put me on testosterone
you want to fight
there was uh there was another really
good bit it was a halloween special and
bart's talking to these robots and
they're like you're a human what's it
like to have feelings he's like i said
i'm a human not a girl
helen was there other chemicals than
testosterone that you or that they put
on you or that you used or anything oh
not that they well i was on a bunch of
psych meds also is the other thing um
because the
testosterone very fun it like it the
rage attacks that it sent me into were
so intense that i ended up actually
hurting myself oh man and wow yeah so i
had to be hospitalized twice for these
reasons rage yeah yeah like it was like
totally
nothing that i was ever prepared for i
don't even think it's normal for like
men like i think it was beyond what is
normal uh well i mean people some people
have anger problems i guess but yeah
maybe
but they put you on
i mean that your body isn't meant for
that stuff right exactly yeah my body's
not meant for it and it was four times
the dose i was supposed to be on i
wonder if the aggressive trans movement
that we're witnessing is part of a
testosterone uptake yes
literally yes it's a bunch of people
with endocrine disorders induced by the
doctors and nurses that they're seeing
to treat their gender dysphoria
so they're getting explained more about
a lot of testosterone and they're
getting aggression because of it a lot
of testosterone and men who are on
estrogen like people's like your brain
and your body is meant to work on the
hormones that you're meant to produce
you're not gonna be a mentally or
physically healthy person if you're
taking a bunch of testosterone as a
woman or a bunch of estrogen and
suppressing your testosterone as a man
and isn't it insane that not only is
that a controversial thing to say
nowadays but that it's it's not even
just not common sensical like people are
angry with us for pointing this out and
they're angry with you for saying hey
like i actually did it it doesn't work
so so
i tweeted this
it's strange that if you oppose sex
change surgery for minors you're
considered right wing
yeah like hands down and the two
responses i got were people saying
you're a transphobe or
you're a liar that's not happening
and so it seems like there's probably a
lot of people who are aligned themselves
with democrats to the left who don't
realize what is happening both with
chemical intervention and surgical
intervention for minors they don't i
mean a friend of mine he goes by
billboard chris on twitter he does this
thing where he goes out to various
public spaces and he has conversations
with people about this trans stuff and
he was talking to this young woman about
how kids are being sterilized which is
what happens if a child is put on
puberty blockers and then cross-sex
hormones they will be sterilized that's
not developed hormones cross-sex
hormones
that's not debatable they will be
infertile they will be sterilized and
this young woman who was so passionately
arguing with him she
refused to believe that children were
being sterilized she was like that's not
happening that's not happening it's like
no that's happening to thousands of
children
it's new technology i think what you
were saying it's important that we have
the conversation it might people may get
angry about stuff in general but it's
such a new technology it's important
that we open up the debate well we do
have this from the christian post which
i'm sure the left will not be happy with
but i don't trust guard has certified
them at 74.5 which i must add is
substantially higher than the daily
beast
so don't tell me
and they say puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones do sterilize children
hospital consent docs show and it can be
interesting too to see their citation
because i would imagine it's not going
to be coming from
their right
consent documents from children's
hospital los angeles obtained by the
california family council revealed the
hospital has also warned patients and
parental guardians that drugs do indeed
yield infertility in those who undergo
the experimental procedures just think
about it okay so the way that your body
matures and you become fertile you
achieve sexual development
is because your sexual organs whether
they are testicles or ovaries during the
process of puberty they receive the
hormones that they're supposed to
receive so testicles during puberty
receive or make testosterone and that is
what allows you to be a fertile male and
it's the same for a woman with estrogen
and progesterone and all that kind of
stuff the menstrual cycle if you
suppress a child's puberty so that that
never happens and then you put the wrong
hormones into their body their organs
are never going to get what they need to
develop to become a fertile adult is
irreversible yes
wow i mean once you miss that oh right
it's not like they can put you through
puberty later on um you don't develop
you don't develop i'm curious speaking
of um
giving this stuff to young people how
old were you when planned parenthood
prescribed this so i was 18. okay so you
were of age yeah i was i was but i i
also i don't know how meaningful that
distinction is because it's not like oh
i'm 17 and you know i'm turning 18
tomorrow now i'm a child that deserves
protection but then that next day on my
birthday i no longer deserve any
protection and anything i want to do to
my body if i want to walk into a planned
parenthood and get 100 milligrams of
testosterone there's nothing wrong with
that planned parenthood for prescribing
me that well it's also insane in any
context that a doctor would say well you
know the patient who has never been on
this medicine before let's say it was a
legitimate treatment which it isn't but
even if it was for a doctor to say this
patient who's never taken this medicine
before is telling me they need more of
it so i'm going to give them more it was
another responsibility
yeah yeah yeah the nurse at the
authority nurse practitioner yeah nurse
practitioner and she had the author or
he or she had the authority to
to to up your dosage without a doctor
yeah yeah and no blood work either
that's another thing wow yeah and and so
what i mean what was that and i have
doing this i have all the records i can
back all of this up planned parenthood
yes it's just
they're the most evil organization
controversy man wow
and most people don't even know and i
want to ask you
what were
the first parts of the process that
really led up to the medical
intervention i mean did you have to see
a therapist first what did you need to
show the people at planned parenthood in
order to be able to get this
prescription i needed to show them two
hundred dollars in cash oh boy yeah
so they wanted to see green pictures of
dead presidents yes that's all they
didn't ask for any medical records they
didn't ask for any information from a
therapist or counselor or psychologist
none of it just money give us the money
we'll give you this medication if you've
been 17 would they have needed your
parents to come in or something in the
in my state yes but there are states
like for example oregon it's 15. you
don't need parental consent to get any
hormones or surgeries in oregon at 15.
and i believe it's the same in
california and there are several states
that are like wasn't it like dc tried to
make it so that if you were 11 you can
get vaccinated without telling your
parents oh my gosh that's unbelievable
like parent this is the crazy thing this
is why we're seeing the thing in florida
the parental rights and education bill
because parents have a right to know
what's happening with their children
and uh i'll ask i'll ask you about this
you know you you have you followed the
parental rights and education bill i'm
sure yeah lies once again from the left
absolutely it's just they do it all the
time with everything that the trans
movement does this they attach
everything to gay rights because they
understand that you know many many many
more people support you know the idea
that uh taking a gay person to some
horrible conversion therapy
conversion therapy camp is terrible um
or you know most people i think would
would kind of not be super threatened
about the idea of a teacher i guess
explaining to a child why the other kid
in their class has two fathers or
something like that so they take those
things that people
you know accept and are not as
controversial and they just smuggle in
the gender ideology and the transiting
kids with it there's a really funny meme
where uh
it was like at a grade school
one of my students came in and was
explaining to the class how they had two
moms and everyone
and then everyone was like cheering and
celebrating a little muslim kid but then
it turned out it was a muslim who had a
polygamous father
with two wives yeah way more people were
people were like clapping like that's so
gender diverse
but no it was actually patriarchy yeah
political political memes comment posted
it and they put the the the like the lib
left over the two moms and the
authoritarian right they put blue over
it
this is this whole conversation is
really kind of reinforcing the the
psychological effect of the internet
that it's having on kids yes like would
you let your kids use the internet
what's your thoughts on that i don't
know it's hard because i think at this
point like you cannot close pandora's
box and i think that when i do have kids
that'll be something that i am
navigating and it'll be very difficult
but i do think that like parents need to
be so much more involved and like one
analogy that i kind of make is like when
your kid wants to go for a sleepover a
lot of parents would ask a lot of
questions they would say like oh well
who is this friend what's their parents
phone number where do they live what do
their parents do maybe you might even
want to meet the parents first or meet
the kid first but when it's the internet
they're spending their time with
thousands of strangers and you have no
idea
i was thinking like today's cult leaders
aren't the people on the ranch doing lsd
with 30 other people and having group
orgies it's the youtubers they're the
cult leaders
yeah yeah yes i want to show you what
your kids are are watching
so this has been removed from youtube
but this was very prominent for several
years
and it's nursery rhymes 3d animation
pewdiepie fighting hitler let me pull
this other one that's i think you know a
lot funnier is the hulk
and hitler and i think i think hitler in
this one is in a bikini i'm not i could
be wrong i think the hit how brave of
her oh no it's actually that i'm just
fighting or whatever and i'm like let's
try to play the sounds
whoa
so wait when did they colorize this
yeah
that wasn't hitler's real voice
are you sure
wait wait okay so i thought that was the
right one but it wasn't playing the
thing that i thought was going to play
let me see yeah look at that victory oh
there we go there we go it was i i saw
it for a second look at his head like
hulk's hands look at this look at this
what is going on
[Music]
so there was this period where this
thing called elsagate was going on and
this was a component of it where
algorithms were creating these videos
automatically and then just auto
uploading them to youtube and parents
would give their ipads to their babies
and their babies
they would turn on nursery rhymes but
then the youtube algorithm would
automatically load up this stuff with
like hitler doing time and a lot worse a
lot worse there was crazy stuff where it
was like kids drinking piss
oh my gosh it was cartoons pornography
and gore
i knew uh there were some that were like
you had children's characters from
beloved franchises basically telling
kids to make bombs just really crazy
stuff wasn't there a thing with peppa
pig where he like yeah yeah yeah i'm
pretty sure but i could be wrong but
there were cartoons where it would auto
generate these videos and the thumbnail
would be like peppa pig drinking piss
and a next to a urinal and then the
video would be him killing other peppa
pigs and stuff like that just really
weird stuff
that they would just make because the
babies can't change the channel the
babies are just staring at it like and
like they're watching this crazy just
being warped by this garbage that's so
scary how old were you when you first
saw porn on the internet
uh i was actually pretty fortunate so my
dad he really tried to protect me and he
like set a lot of like safety parental
regulations on my computer so i got to
avoid it until i was like 11 or 12. did
you know it existed i thought you were
going to say like 15 or 16 11 12. wow
did you know it was out there
um
i i i can't really remember i remember
um one i was on youtube and it was like
back when you could actually find porn
on youtube and i was like looking
oh really yeah that it's just me it's it
there's like what's in my butt challenge
and it shows there's like a video of two
two guys just you know literally doing
it gross yeah um yeah i remember finding
something and and it wasn't even
anything like hardcore or anything but i
mean i was a child so i was pretty uh
concerned about it i didn't understand
what was going on yeah i mean that's
horrible what about you sheamus when
you're a little older i mean but how old
were you when you first saw porn on the
internet i don't i didn't um i well
actually when i was young i had a friend
of mine we were just out walking and he
like pulled porn out of his wall and i
was like i'm not supposed to look at
that stuff on a video no no he like he
literally had a physical crinkled up
damage that he had like in his wall and
i was like don't show me that
i think how were you when you ian you
told me the story before that as soon as
you you know you're a teenager when when
the internet was discovered you were the
first person to put porn on that there's
too many jokes to make right now that i
will not make on the internet um i saw
like playboy when i was like six or
eight or something my you know my friend
had him his dad had him in the basement
so i don't i don't i've been using
computers for a really long time but
honestly my
i think i was way older than you are
maybe 14.
so for me a lot of the stuff i was doing
online was like flash animation stuff i
wasn't like it never occurred to me to
do those things yeah i was like 21. you
know what actually i did i should i
should mention i think when i was like
15 i was using someone's computer and it
had a virus and just pornographic images
started popping up so yeah there's a lot
of pop-ups in general just pop-ups of
like you know russian
uh
single hot ladies and then it's like
pornographic take the phones away from
your kids do not let your kids
these big tech companies don't let their
kids have access to the internet
no and and think i mean look
they'll let your kid have access to it
that's why you have to protect them
that's why you can't let them look at
this stuff the first thing i thought
when you mentioned tumblr was my
goodness it's so dangerous to allow kids
to go on the internet because i think a
lot of parents would not even know no
and that's exactly the problem they
don't know because they don't make that
connection where it's like okay the
kid's staring at the phone but what
they're doing is they're communicating
with other people even if it's not a
direct chat when they're scrolling
something like they're getting messages
from other people those are other real
people posting those things and that's
what your child is consuming and i think
a lot of parents like they don't make
that connection they just think oh like
she's looking at pictures or something
let me pull up this story from
timcast.com florida mother suing school
that secretly discussed gender
transition with her middle schooler
quote this is happening all over the
nation she said a florida school was
sued after it helped a student
transition gender without informing or
seeking the consent of the teen's
parents
january littlejohn that's her name said
she was outraged when school officials
at deer lake middle school in
tallahassee secretly discussed gender
and transgenderism with her daughter
without her knowledge this is happening
all over the nation the same protocol is
in place in many many schools across
districts everywhere and even the guides
being used to dictate these transgender
support plans that cut parents out even
have the same language little john said
her then 13 year old daughter was
friends with a group of students who
transitioned to the opposite gender a
group
her daughter reportedly expressed her
own confusion over gender during the
onset of the covet 19 pandemic little
john later discovered the student's
school had been developing a transgender
support plan with a young teen in august
of 2020.
littlejohn said she was told by the
school she could not be involved because
of a non-discrimination law she was also
told by administrators that they could
not disclose what had happened during
their meetings with her child
eventually we did see the transgender
support plan which was a six page
document that they completed with my
daughter who was 13 at the time behind
closed doors where they asked her
questions that would have absolutely
impacted her safety
so this is why they passed the parental
rights and education bill because
schools are withholding this information
and parents have
rights over their kids and this is like
a tame example too if you go to there's
a really interesting sub stack it's
called pit parents p-i-t-t parents it
stands for parents with inconvenient
truths about transgenderism there's just
like
endless testimonies of these parents and
the absolute hell that the schools put
them through where the schools kind of
they it's extremely manipulative they
triangulate with the child against the
parents and it's just it's horrific
they'll get you know child productive
services involved i know parents who
have had child protective services
called in them multiple times because
they don't want to transition their 12
year old girl who's been convinced that
she's a boy at school that is definitely
one of those it's horrific you mentioned
in a previous uh segment just earlier
that
you know you're on tumblr and they tell
you things like just experiment like cut
your hair yes and then when you do they
start praising you and loves you through
with praise there were a few there was a
subreddit for d transitioners i don't
know if you're familiar it's gone now
yeah
um i don't believe it's gone i believe
that it's been down at certain times i
mean if it is gone then uh well there
was one i remember a long time ago that
i remember it disappeared okay that
might have been the first one because
there is one i think that's still active
right now i don't really browse it so
i'm not sure if it got banned recently
or something but there was also a
website that's gone that was for
detransitioners and the point they were
making was
if you go online and you're feeling
these things the only thing you will see
is positive yes you will see no negative
um elements you will see no uh d
transitioners yes you will see nothing
but it was the best thing i ever did
when in reality it's because the people
who question it are getting banned and
the people who bring up these
conversations are getting banned as well
exactly because the far left and big
tech is doing everything within their
power to erase the existence of people
like you
exactly and also i mean the trans
community itself really does operate
like a cult like there's not just pure
censorship there's all these social
mechanisms involved that discourage
people from listening to people like me
i mean just recently a popular trans uh
influencer
was coming after me and just making
videos about me like completely
misrepresenting me demonizing me like
calling me a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and like
all sorts of i don't know if i'm allowed
to say that
the worst
one is i'm sorry you said the truth
i take it back i didn't mean it um about
what she said this about oh there you go
all the advertisers accept your apology
and though okay i'm really
that's all right let it out yeah i'm
sorry nordvpn
we have virtual [ __ ] okay i'm sorry bro
i should know that yeah i'm sorry nobody
really cares um but yeah i mean this
person biological male by the way uh
just like hurling horrible insults at me
completely demonizing me um and it's
just like all the followers just eat it
up instead of instead of engaging with
me on what i'm actually saying or maybe
listening to like maybe like she is
telling the truth it just has to be no
she's lying no she's being paid no she's
a chill
maybe this biological male is upset that
you're like actually a woman and they're
jealous in some way this this what
you're describing perhaps can be
extrapolated and expanded to a common
occurrence between what we colloquially
colloquially refer to i always through
that word
referred to as the left and the right
talk about taxes talk about ukraine talk
about anything and you are describing
the exact phenomenon
the left as we call it is the parent
group that typically makes things up
demonizes falsely represents smears and
won't come on the show yeah don't try
ableism make excuse for i don't i think
these people for the most part are uh
they're grifters right
that's they project on us but i'll just
i'll say right now look call whatever
you want if we are inviting people on
the show
to come and explain their ideas and they
won't do it it's because they don't have
any ideas it's because all they are is a
wad of emotional fire screaming into the
wind and when you say please explain
they don't have anything to explain
they're just mad it's like that comic
let's say the comic where the guy's like
i'm angry the other guy's like here's a
solution and then he burns it he's like
i don't want a solution i want to be
angry
they have to protect their followers
from witnessing their ideas being
challenged so i'm also curious about the
role the adults in your life played i
know you mentioned that your parents
tried to
help you yeah what happened with other
adults were there educators
administrators parents friends who were
involved
yeah so um the only other adults that
really played like a major feature in
this whole situation was my school
guidance counselor and my school
psychologist the therapist and they were
both
very affirming to me so the school
guidance counselor i i came and told her
like you know my parents don't accept me
for being trans um but i feel like if i
don't transition i'm going to kill
myself basically is what i said and did
you feel that way at that time that you
were i was going through i was really
going through it like i had a lot going
on in my life and i interpreted it all
as it's because i'm trans but really
like the problems were much deeper it
wasn't all about being born in the wrong
body and i'm only asking not to accuse
you of misleading at that time in your
life i've just heard people say that
they are told to say like i will kill
myself if i'm not affirmed so there is
that there is that but you also do just
kind of believe it because
like the thing about this is that like a
lot of people who are drawn to this like
they're they are drawn to something so
drastic and so unhinged from reality
because they're going through intense
emotional pain
and so like it really does feel to you
that this is the only solution like this
is the only possibility that you have is
to like do this kind of crazy thing and
transition and then maybe you'll have a
chance at a happy life did it help your
psychology
my
did it did transitioning help stepping
into that realm that it helped you no no
i definitely just
derailed my life i'm looking at rachel
levine the i don't know if she's
trans woman um and she said that top
biden health or top in health official
that's rachel says trans youth being
quote driven to depths of despair the
way i look at it is that children are
being driven to the depths of despair
yes and so they're they're thinking
there's something like you were saying
you were experiencing depression at the
age of 13. because the world is nuts and
it's been exposed at how nuts it is with
the propaganda ministry and all this
crap i mean there's lots of reasons to
be depressed outside of your personal
life i think that exposition is driving
people insane and including kids
brother and it's like it's again it's
it's selection bias because a lot of the
kids that are drawn to this are kids
that already have deep emotional issues
like for example i think there's
statistics on like the california foster
care system and like a hugely
disproportionate amount of kids in the
foster care system are identifying as
trans and of course the law in
california is like a trans them on the
public dime
um but yeah so i think you have a lot of
kids that they have
trauma or
you know autism is another big one
kids with autism really struggle when
they're growing up you have these kids
who
like they're really going through some
very deep struggles and they get they
cling to this idea that they're really
meant to be someone else and then all
the adults tell them yes you're really
meant to be someone else and then
it it creates a feeling of desperation
and so
levine is
kind of taking advantage of that for a
political reason and without really
exploring you know why are these kids so
desperate if you have a score check real
quick the chat is saying ian natural 20.
natural 20 baby let's confirm that
critical you know if you could go back
to when you were 13 i rolled a 39 again
uh no no that's a 63 upside down my bad
it's all right you already gave it it's
a 39 final answer if you go back to when
you were 13 and think like if something
was different if you had some sort of
experience or outlet or something
that could have helped even remotely
what kind of stuff can you think do you
think of um i think it would have helped
me a lot to have like
um
honestly better relationships with the
adults in my life um i just didn't feel
like
i was really kind of like heard
and um yeah i was just kind of allowed
to like recede into this loneliness and
isolation and i think that i i you know
i would have really benefited from some
gentle help to you know
help me kind of get out there and like
make some real friends and stuff like
that being heard is a key element of a
human stability like for parents to
allow even if the kid they don't
understand what the kid's saying it's
important i think to let the kid
listen to the kid yeah yeah that's what
i always tell parents because they like
a lot of parents come to me like asking
like how do i talk to my kid about this
and it's like yeah your kid is gonna be
saying a lot of like ideological
mumbo-jumbo that you don't agree with
but like you have to kind of resist just
focusing on that and arguing and just
like let them express themselves in the
way that they know how
so i would like to ask you then if you
were speaking either to your own child
or you know a child you were in some
position of authority over and they
basically said this to you that they
felt that they were
truly
born in the wrong body what is the
approach what's the response i know you
sort of outlined some some general rules
but i'm curious what you would say to
them
so if i had
a long-term like relationship like this
okay yeah if this was my child then yeah
i would
i would do my best to
try to understand like their actual
emotional experience because i think for
me it was definitely a way of
understanding my emotional experience
but it wasn't correct it was all
ideological and like i learned it online
and all this kind of stuff but i was
having real emotions under there so i
think that um what i would do in that
situation as the adult is to try to
connect with that young person on the
things that are real like their
authentic feelings and concerns and
doubts and anxieties and like just like
try to bring that out and make them feel
supported in that and so they don't feel
so desperate to like cling to these
ideological beliefs yeah i think that's
a very good way of putting it and one
thing i find which is very insidious
about these extremely effective far-left
ideologies is they do a fantastic job of
seizing onto actual trauma or actual
pain that people have experienced and
then attaching ideological language to
it yes and then when anyone challenges
that ideological language or stance the
person feels as if their trauma is
precisely precisely and that's why you
hear like you're denying my existence
because that's exactly the process that
is happening all of the emotional
baggage is being packaged up into this
trans box this gender identity box and
then when you misgender that person or
when you argue about the trans ideology
it literally feels like you're taking
that whole box full of everything
important to that person and throwing it
out
yo this is the deepest conversation i've
had in life
i think one of the issues is actually
this is awesome um
can i ask you about your childhood is it
i don't wanna sure like where what kind
of light family do you have were you
guys poor were you rich
um i would say my family was upper
middle class so my parents were both
professionals um and
yeah i grew up in a mostly
similarly socio-economic area with
mostly you know caucasian people i
wonder is this phenomenon happening in
low-income areas it it's interesting it
it happens a lot in
suburban areas of all
classes i would say from my experience
like the suburbia thing is is a common
denominator and then it also happens in
kind of like the most disadvantaged kids
like the foster care kids right i was
just thinking i i wonder there's a
component to this of
if the worst trauma you've experienced
is based on things you're seeing on the
internet versus i don't know like your
house burning down or you know
gangbangers shooting at you
then if someone comes to you and says we
don't respect your ideology you'd be
upset by that
if you're someone who grew up in you
know gang neighborhoods super low-income
areas drug dealers people are being
beaten you've seen people get murdered i
don't know how much you'd actually care
about someone challenging your pronouns
yeah i think that that is a part of it
but i would kind of push back on the
idea that these are kids who have never
experienced any adversity so even if
they come from a physically sheltered
and and provided for
uh upbringing i think that there is a
huge common denominator between like
various forms of kind of
relational traumas or just unresolved
adversities that they've been through
like um
divorce is a really big one i know that
a lot of uh you know d transitioners
they've had you know
parents who one of the parents was
abusive or an alcoholic maybe they
weren't uh you know extremely poor or
anything but they had to you know grow
up with like a an addict in the house
and for me my one of the things that was
most personally impactful for me and my
mental health issues growing up was a
childhood grief that i had really never
processed it was a major major loss
what do you think the next 20 years will
look like with all of these kids who are
transitioning
oh man um i'm really scared for
[Music]
a lot of people because you already see
like people i consider myself very lucky
in that i didn't really have any
long-term physical consequences but like
i know people who had their breasts cut
off when they were 16 or had their
testicles cut off when they were 17 or
18.
and it's just like these people
are really hurting like it's it's
extreme it's a lot to
wrap your head around and deal with when
you're you know when you've been through
that and then you have like all the
little kids right now who are you know
they're the ones going through the
puberty blockers and they're being put
on the cross sex hormones at some point
they're going to be 22 23 24 25 and
they're gonna have to you know start
thinking back on their childhood and
think like how much was this really my
decision and and like what are the
consequences of this so i think there's
going to be a lot to reckon with with
those people and i don't know if they
will all be people who very clearly
regret it maybe they'll just be very
psychologically
disturbed i think parents have to tell
their kids what to do yeah i think
they're they're i've heard a lot of
parents say things like you know i want
my kids to just
you know do what they want to do like i
want them to tell me and i'm like your
kids don't know what they want to do man
yeah like you need to you take your kid
and they're like you got to be you got
to be giving your kids something to do
as as soon as they're born you should be
showing them things you shouldn't be
assuming that they're stupid
children human babies are not stupid
they lack knowledge
children are not stupid they lack
knowledge there are some stupid people
don't get me wrong but children as a
whole are as smart as anybody else but
they lack knowledge and they lack
certain developmental functions in the
brain like risk assessment things like
that which is why they need parents to
guide them which means
a seven-year-old doesn't understand why
it would be great to learn french
and you'll be like trust me the french
lessons are going to be awesome when
that when these when these people grow
up you learn learning another language
and they're in their late 20s and
they're like oh i speak two or three
languages wow all of a sudden they have
this valuable skill it's easier to
navigate the world musical instruments
same issue i don't want to do piano
lessons parents if you've got kids who
hate doing the the panel lesson it's
because you need to get them to hang out
with other kids who play music too so
they can be with their peers but then
when those kids are older and they're
really good at instrument they're going
to be so grateful they can do it the
problem is i think parents are just like
tell me what you want we'll do it
well kids don't know what they want they
want to be
you know astronauts when they're seven
it's like okay we want to be an
astronaut you got to start doing these
things right now and they're going to be
like
math
and and science but i want to go to
space now i think another big issue is
that parents have really had their
instincts and their decision making
capabilities undermined by this idea
that
oh everything needs to be deferred to
the experts and if you disagree with the
expert well you're just uneducated and
you're just
obsolete and you're outdated and you
don't have the up-to-date scientific
information and there's so many parents
out there i mean there are those crazy
parents who like they're really into
transiting their kid but there's also a
lot of parents where i just don't think
that they have the confidence when some
you know
ivy league educated doctor tells them
that their kid needs to be put on
puberty blockers and that it's very safe
and effective that they don't have the
the confidence to actually like go look
into that themselves and then oppose
that authority figure can we just
acknowledge that there is a happy medium
between believing the earth is flat and
saying i'm not a biologist and i can't
tell you what a woman is like perhaps
there's a point where you don't have to
be an expert to just point out some
basic things
you know don't believe the crazy guy on
the internet who's like nasa is lying to
you the earth is flat and then it's like
okay well that's kind of nuts i think
the earth is round but then you've got
someone over here a supreme court just
being like i am not a biologist i don't
know what a woman is it's like okay well
i think i do
yeah yeah i agree and i just want to
mention that when it comes to something
as basic and fundamental as your child's
gender right you know the differences
between boys and girls you know what
your child is the doctor the expert
already told you as soon as they were
born that they were a boy or a girl and
this idea that i mean they guessed yeah
you're right they made a guess but this
idea that's ridiculous this idea that um
you know like the school guidance
counselor is an expert on your kid but
you aren't is so backwards the gym
teacher told me that they didn't know
what a woman was so i defer to the gym
teacher well i guess my point is like
obviously there are some like specific
insights you can get from a medical
professional right but the idea that
this this like guidance counselor
fundamentally knows your child's
identity and you've completely missed it
it's it's asinine but that's the whole
undercurrent throughout all of this is
that the parents are bad the parents
don't know what they're doing their
parents are stupid listen to the experts
and if the parents won't let you listen
to the experts and you need to take the
child away from the parents
yeah let's go to super chats if you have
not already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with everyone you know and love uh
because grassroots marketing really is
the most powerful thing uh we've spent
zero dollars marketing this show it's
all grassroots all people sharing stuff
so really do appreciate it head over
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only show coming up it'll
be published at around 11 p.m
and as a member you're supporting our
journalists and get those super chats in
with your questions because we are going
to start reading them now
mr slendy says
can men get pregnant or are we not
allowed to have an opinion on abortion
both cannot be true lefties you've
painted yourself into a logical paradox
oh they don't care logic doesn't matter
to them no truthful power i agree
there's no logic
you know i'm just i'm a person who
prefers some logic in the arguments
there needs to be rules to understand
how the system works and so when they
say like here's our position in this
thing i say what is your basis for this
thing and they're like shut up do you
agree with us or not exactly it's like a
guy
all right
let's see what we got
rolling ones
let's see
matt nill says tim did you see the news
that the roe v wade draft leaked may be
a cover for the massive info about
pfizer also did you see cdc admits it
purchased location information to track
people if people were vast uh or within
curfew curfew did see that i don't
really care for the conspiracy theory
about covering something up i mean the
pfizer stuff did come out
i don't know if you guys saw that where
pfizer's profits were up this quarter by
like 75
or something after
come on pfizer such a racket oh man
pharmaceutical when do people fall out
and fall back in love with
pharmaceutical companies right allergies
fear of fear of covet basically i would
i would like to file a complaint against
all the trees who are assaulting me
right now you go outside and there's
just green everywhere you're drinking
water the pollen dehydrates you tickles
your throat but if you drink a lot of
water and eat less sugar you should be
okay real raymond g stanley jr says
sheamus today's cartoon was super
fantastic oh thank you so much which one
was that y'all better go check it out
you guys are just gonna have to watch it
someday when you're older it's uh
no i'm kidding guys go watch it right
now freedom tunes we're also releasing
one on thursday you're very much going
to enjoy it
all right
cyrus inertial says i sent an email to
spin the ufo a few weeks ago about
getting an i.t job with you fine folks
but no reply are there still open it
positions or did my email just suck um
well there's potentially the issue is
just that we have i think 12 000 emails
yeah so you're doing a good job and just
i don't handle any tim cast employee any
of that so if don't message me with that
i'm only working on the charity stuff
which is completely different
organization
all right
raymond g stanley jr says guys i laughed
so hard during the drive to work this
morning the members show was so off the
rails i thought tim might actually drop
kick ian
last night i got a lot of responses
about the members only show last night
that was awesome yeah i think a lot of
people were mad at you i thought i felt
that in the air so the the but the main
issue was that we were talking about the
story in philadelphia where a guy on the
train
was raping a woman
and nobody did anything i know and i was
like i would drop kick the dude and nina
was like i'm not getting involved yeah
we were talking about getting involved
with a woman killing her fetus is that
similar to like seeing someone get
attacked on the subway that was kind of
like we never really went too deep into
that schism i like that word schism i
think you said that earlier um and then
what else there's another thing we were
talking about we would do but basically
like would you come to someone's aid if
they were getting attacked and then is
that also like a baby in the womb like
will you come to their aid if the mother
is going to abort it well i think the
main thing that people were concerned
about was like you said you would not
intervene to protect the woman and i
said i would yeah
the conversation got pretty twisted
pretty quick i've actually been thinking
about this today like if someone's
getting attacked
then i mean calling the cops isn't
enough you've got to make a split second
time training are you going to get
involved right i mean i think they have
cell nodes down in the subways now but
the issue was
i don't think i i think you make a good
legal point about how the left run
cities like oh you're the one who's
going to go to prison if you try and
stop this guy so most people are like
i'm not getting involved
you know back in the day you'd be like
if i get involved i know i'm not getting
in trouble i'm i'm helping nowadays it's
like that dude will sue you and you'll
lose you'll get arrested
like the criminal will sue you they
could be making a movie for all i know
there are those stories about criminals
who are breaking into someone's house
and then sue the homeowner after they
get injured breaking in insanity that
was a great show last night i highly
recommend people check it out
yeah danny's lit
danny
yeah yeah danny was cool yeah it was
cool he loved it
all right what's what's going on mike we
stuck here all right
eric redbeard says carlin borsenko makes
the point that republicans just lost
every woman who left the democrats in
the last two years you'll lose every
election for the rest of your lives
declares uh declares for lp thoughts
no idea i'm not a woman
i don't even know what a woman is no i i
don't think so i don't think that's the
case but i don't know i'm pretty sure
making predictions lydia is going to
vote republican yeah
yeah i would say that i don't think that
every woman just left the republican
party i think that women who left the
sorry the democrat party i think that
women that left the democrat party for a
reason are going to be like perfect this
is exactly why i left the democrat party
and the fact they're spazzing out about
this is only going to make them more
committed and carlin is
um perhaps misled about this i would say
i don't know greg duvier says ian great
job playing devil's advocate on the
members only segment last night you even
you even fooled tim until he saw
something on your screen giving away you
were acting like bill gates great job
acting
he was lying it was i'm not bill gates
fanboy
was making an argument about like the
over consumption or something and then i
made them oh gosh it got dark yeah i
made that i made the joke that he must
be reading bill gates to make this yeah
i was talking about like having too many
people what that even means it's just
such a good show it was such a good show
i'd love to go have another one of those
and it was not family friendly no they
were like really really gruesome danny
was like this is what the after show is
this should be every show i was like
we'd be banned in two seconds dude don't
let your kids listen yeah because this
show is kind of like you know uh
we gotta add we gotta we gotta add the
opening monologue from a comedian and a
musical guest and then we'll be just
like stephen colbert yeah no thank you
but uh i we we do try to make this so
that you know people can turn this on
and their kids might be in the room and
we don't you know say nasty words just
because
people like uh some sanctity around
their families
all right
trash panda says looking for some advice
from sheamus i had a short conversation
with a good friend and co-worker and he
believes in abortion up to birth
and it would be better to kill a newborn
than uh adoption homes
i'm curious what advice he's asking for
like there isn't a specific question
how should he account for you respond to
that
that's i mean that's a good question how
should you respond to the how should you
respond to someone who thinks it's okay
to murder a child after they've been
born i'm not sure what response you
could get at that person if they've
genuinely said that if this is a case
where you think that this person's
principles lead them to that position
you need to expose that to them and help
them understand if this is a person who
says that they are okay with
slaughtering a child after they've been
born i think
i'm not sure if a conversation is going
to affect that i would say to pray for
them i would i would say that maybe you
can try to persuade them that human life
has value but i don't know if someone
doesn't believe human life is
intrinsically valuable i don't know what
you can say to them if that makes sense
i feel like that's not a position based
on like
any kind of logic on their part i feel
like that's a very emotional position
and i don't know if you're gonna get
through to them yeah well it's like my
friend says i can murder babies how how
should i respond to that
they said uh that it's you're better off
killing the born in infant than giving
it up for adoption which i don't agree
that's insane like that's a horrifically
evil thing to say yeah i know kids of
kids that were adopted that are
phenomenal fantastic humans like maybe
if that if your friend meets somebody
that's been adopted or whose parents
have been adopted that might help yeah
this this person creates a very twisted
world overview and uh maybe this person
was raised in like foster care and had a
very bad experience or something
mima type says matt walsh is basically
making the libertarian argument we've
been saying this for a while it's called
right to evict the woman can decide to
not be pregnant but there is a duty to
save the life of the baby if possible
that's not what matt walsh is not at all
matt walsh is saying if there's an
instance where there is a procedure
which is required to save the life of
the mother and it puts the child at risk
you can perform the procedure but you
need to do everything possible to save
the child he is absolutely not saying
that you can just evict a child from
their from their mother's uterus
brandon hill says i am mostly
anti-abortion but this was the wrong
hill to die on at this time now we face
ending the filibuster packing the courts
and losing the midterms because the
moderates side with pro-choice we lost
the culture war
i do not believe it is true that the
moderate side with the democrats with
pro-choice um
i think the issue is the ignorant do
because i'm somebody who's repeatedly
said over and over again that i fall in
the more safe legal and rare category
but there's no one to vote for who
supports that so i don't know what i'm
supposed to do well also vote for the
country's you know pretty split on this
50 50. i can tell you what the country's
not split on inflation they don't like
it i can tell you the country doesn't
like high gas prices they don't like
that food costs more than it's costed in
our lifetimes they don't like the fact
that our country looks ridiculous on the
foreign stage right now
i i serious question are there like
millennial women who are really planning
on getting abortions and they're worried
about like a woman who's not got an
abortion is like i might need one and
now this is bad for me because like the
blue states aren't going to be getting
rid of this yeah and also
look
it's not as if um when you look at this
this issue you're absolutely correct but
also it's gonna as far as i'm aware even
if this passes stay legal in the blue
states but it's hilarious because the
left is going
oh my goodness you know everyone's gonna
vote for us now because of this and at
the same time they're threatening
violence and saying we need to riot and
have a revolution so i wouldn't be too
concerned i i think the left is really
set on handing us a victory here i'm not
sure what's going to happen but if the
right does anything which could be
considered politically unpopular the
left is going to react by like freaking
out and writing and making themselves
look like idiots so
all right kyle says helena how do you
rate male privilege during your brief
tenure is it all that is hyped up to be
i don't think i experienced being a man
at all what years
i i i can't really i mean i don't
believe in like the whole privilege
oppression stuff but um
i i just hesitate to say that i had a
experience of a man because i don't
think i did
there there was a uh there was this this
woman who identified as a man and she
said her experience was so different and
it was sad she was like
men are not
like nobody cared about your feelings
anymore men or women
that it was like a very different
experience that was very cold and lonely
yeah there was a i believe a lesbian
journalist who dressed up as a man on an
undercover project and i thought that
was interesting but on the other hand
that is a woman being treated as a man
as opposed to a man being treated as a
man so probably not going to enjoy it
but they didn't know that
no i understand no i understand that but
it's possible i mean because men and
women are different that the emotional
reaction a woman would have to being
treated like a man would be negative
whereas for a man
i don't want to be lauded with emotion
when i walk around during the day like i
i appreciate people that kind of leave
me alone and let me be
you can kind of see that happening it's
like when women when when men try to
like joke with women the way they joke
with other men women take it like so
badly and they get they they think it's
like the man being mean to her
personally
yeah no exactly it can happen and so i
mean men and women are different and if
you treat a woman like a man she's
probably not going to be all that happy
let me let me tell you guys something
i've talked about this before uh so a
guy walks into his office let's call it
a law firm
and uh
i see sheamus i walk in i see sheamus
and i go oh sheamus that's a great shirt
man where'd you get that
you're actually looking pretty good
you're working out you get a haircut or
something
hey man then i pat him on the shoulder
and
what are you talking to me for that's
that's that's that's that's
like a fine interaction yeah yeah guy
was like whoa yeah you've been hitting
my shirt yeah i'd be like hey i
appreciate it i haven't but you know i
this is a cool shirt and then you walk
up he grabs him on the shoulder pats and
was like great outfit man that suit's
looking sharp dude you're looking good
now imagine a guy walks up to a woman in
a dress and he goes oh wow you're
looking good you're hitting the gym
karen oh nice dress patch on the
shoulder he's fired yeah 100 i mean to
be fair you threw some oohs in there
that the guy didn't get regardless even
even if those weren't there like oh
sheamus working out popular but even if
those wasn't weren't there i agree with
you that that would be
if a guy went up to a guy and was like
he was like hey man you're looking
pretty good you're hitting the gym
that's a great outfit by the way you get
a haircut or something he's looking good
hey man keep up the good work here's the
here's those those reports from last
week say the exact same thing to a man
oh you're looking good man you hit the
gym karen that's a great outfit by the
way you get a haircut or something
you're looking great here hear the
reports you'd be like i think it's
because adult men and women cannot be
friends it could i mean it might be a
stretch
but i think that's why you have a
girlfriend and a boyfriend and you have
one because you choose to go down that
path towards marriage or relationship
with one they can be friends they're
just different dynamics yeah
and i think that you i think usually if
a guy
were to come up to like a female
co-worker that he's not really you know
close friends with or anything and and
be like
you know
you look so good you've been going to
the gym like usually that would be from
like a flirtatious place there's just
different dynamics there yeah well i
definitely agree with you ian especially
if you're in a committed relationship if
you're married right there's just the
dynamics are completely different
between yourself and the opposite sex
it's not as if you're in a position
where it's like oh i could just be
friends with everybody oh yeah if you
went out and got hammered with some girl
but you were married at the time like
that's crazy yeah but you could get
hammered with a dude and just have fun
like your friend i don't know i i yeah i
agree
this one i i'd like to see what you guys
think in chat can men and women adult
men and women be friends
super chat
all right cal miller says a civil war in
the united states will be the end of
taiwan nato and the global order
agreed
anything no just all right there we go
yeah civil war would trigger a bunch of
that a global conflict
delhiopoulos says over the last few
years i've been obsessed with the cold
war and doing a lot of research on it
and right now america is giving off some
serious 1980 soviet union vibes oh man
well
i guess we only have a few years huh
elaborate well the 80s was the end of
the soviet union yeah they've gotten
back
and fell apart basically and uh i wonder
what's going on now wild
so so do we expect the oligarchs to come
in and say we're running the show now
like klaus schwab and blackrock and all
this stuff they're going to come in and
be like it'd be amazing business as
usual elon musk starts like going around
with a bunch of like paramilitary guys
taking over factories and he's like i'm
in charge now
memes and then he starts posting me
that's what he actually just did crazy
things
jeff bezos already has a bunch of
factories all over the place he doesn't
even have to go in and coerce aren't
they isn't amazon buying malls or
something i don't know they're doing
something like that
yeah
all right
timothy barzotti says both breaking
points hosts agree that if there is one
person to blame for roe overturning it
is uh it is not trump but rather ruth
bader ginsburg for not retiring and
greeting out the first female president
hillary
that's interesting interesting uh
statement someone mentioned that to me
on twitter i think earlier today too if
if rgb had resigned when
obama was president then obama could
have then it would be 5'4 upholding
roving yeah you justices gotta figure
out when enough is enough step down when
it's time to step down they're arrogant
they were all arrogant and art ruther
ginsberg wanted to be there to greet the
first female president
so she's like i am not retiring for this
gonna be historic and then dude
everybody hated hillary are you nuts
hillary was so bad
crazy
brave new clown world says the civil war
was started over much less
look up the moral tariff it was the
straw that broke the camel's back get
ready for civil war round two
look that up
m-o-r-r-i-l-l tariff interesting
i don't i hope you guys don't want civil
war
that's the most this i mean i don't
think if you haven't been no but people
people might want peaceful divorce okay
but that's that's what federalism it's
like okay so
red states can have red state laws and
blue states can have blue state laws and
you can move between them yep actually
that's a pretty good system yeah the
problem is the democrats are like we
want the entire country to uphold our
way of life and so gun rights is the
easiest example you know billy joe in
the mountains of west virginia doesn't
need to be constrained by the same gun
laws as anthony in new york city that's
why i think it would be more of a
revolution than a civil war because it
would be like the federal government's
gone too far kind of thing and the
states have had enough
well all right let's read some more
jason take says big fan of of all you
guys do i would love to build you a
conference table out of solid walnut
with clear epoxy inlays and ian
could fill it with some crazy rocks what
did it cost as long as i can personally
deliver it i don't know what we would do
at the table maybe soon though uh we
have a new table that's getting built
it's going to have everyone's going to
be able to control their own headphone
volume
could you do that same thing with wall
like wall what is this called panel wall
wall with this wall wall wall could you
do that could you do like inlaid epoxy
wall paneling that we could put stuff in
our walls are actually floors yeah they
are vinyl flooring yeah we bought a
bunch of vinyl flooring and then you
just cut it and stick it to the wall
it's very thick and it's very heavy
looking good
it's good fun
jn says the opposite of life is death
not choice the bible says choose life
fact check sheamus what is that
um the opposite of
life is not choice i mean is death not
choice the opposite of life is
definitely yeah i mean well because i
think they're making an argument about
the terms pro-life and pro-choice it's
like yeah they're pro-death
pro-death
lisa p up he says abortion is a
euphemism what's done isn't an abortion
the only proper word is murder not only
is it a euphemism the word itself is
entirely inaccurate as it pertains to
the act
interesting
so maybe we need new words
so you can say you know emergency
medical procedure for when it's an
emergency medical procedure and
termination of the baby just call it
termination of the baby
killing well because the left means
something different when they say
abortion i think but here's the thing i
don't actually know that they do because
you're right that they'll try to take
these hard cases that they will describe
differently but they'll take these hard
cases that they describe as abortions uh
or
so the the examples we've mentioned were
like a procedure is performed that puts
the child at risk rather than something
that directly kills the child but then
they'll try to use that to like justify
going in and killing a child and not
only that but like going and killing a
child for any reason so what they are
defending at the end of the day is what
we would describe as abortion what what
the left describes as abortion ranges
from
the needless termination of a fetus
killing of the baby
all the way to the baby is already dead
and needs to be removed from the womb
they call that an abortion
so like you there needs to be a better
way to describe it i hear you i guess my
point is that
when they talk about these other
instances they're using it to try to
justify
legal completely legal abortion up until
the point of um birth basically
all right well
all right jay champagne says ian i saw
the low roll beginning of the show but
call of cthulhu is an rpg that uses a
d100 for skill checks and in that system
lower rolls are better than high ones oh
there you go then i nailed that four
ashton
d rojas says the chaos flame description
sounds like the frenzied flame from
elden ring where you go mad by being
exposed to it and spread it around yeah
i like that metaphor that people's rage
is like fire what was it that like the
it's chaotic fire it's destructive and
it consumes fire itself has a logic to
it in the right contained environment it
functions exactly as you expect it to so
it's only when the environment is
chaotic the fire takes on that behavior
billy masik says told my
thirteen-year-old niece to catch a
lightning bug then asked if she had the
right to kill it even though she clearly
had the power i then said if you didn't
want to be responsible for it why did
you grab it what if someone grabs a
lightning bug and throws it at her and
it gets in her hair
and then she's like ah get it off me get
it off me
and then then
speaking of i had a stink bug on my
finger earlier and i didn't know it was
a stink bug so i squeezed it and it
juiced all over my finger yeah i still
try i gotta go juice all over your
fingers
don't sniff it what are you doing i'm
just an animal you know
well all right
iggy the incubus says where was the
uproar over scotus case five months ago
when it initially came out that row was
effectively done anyways this feels like
an attempt to galvanize for midterms and
distract from the disinfo disinfo
governing board i don't know about the
midterms man we're six months away from
the midterms that's eternity in politics
yo that's why they call it an october
surprise the news will come out a week
before the midterms and it'll be like
joe biden farted and then everyone's
gonna go ah and they're gonna forget all
about this
oh here's a good one scrobaca says
amazon put out a press release that they
would start paying up to four thousand
dollars for travel for staff for medical
procedures including abortion yesterday
before the scotus leak
we talked about this on the after show
last night yep basically a cynical
horrifically evil business decision
people who kill their babies are
actually cheaper as employees than
people who have children because you
don't have to pay them the wage that
would be necessary to care for a family
michael hope says helena is spot on i
used tumblr as a teenager and was
completely radicalized in the same way
they promote and praise mental disorders
yeah they call it neurodivergence right
yeah and like you like list all of your
mental problems yeah and you
self-diagnose as the different ones and
it yeah it goes deep yeah wow
all right
kc says yo ireland you can probably just
ask her a question without pre-prefacing
as a trans four to ian you guys rock
who's ireland who are they referring to
i don't know i don't know
is that racist that's extremely
offensive first of all you can refer to
me without having ireland in there do
you understand
but as a as a formerly trans person
all right sire williamson says what she
is saying is so true because of my
intersex defect i had to take 200
milligrams of testosterone just to bring
me up to a safe level life-threatening
low levels for a man and my feelings
were all over can't imagine a woman yeah
yep
interesting
all right
thomas bowman says tim cast for 2024
sheamus as vp
first of all first pla first place does
not go to the vice president okay i will
be running the it is shibcast irl
all right murph tri says i got an ad on
youtube for puberty blockers but it was
advertised as a treatment for cpp
immediately realized this was their
cover story for the treatment what's cpp
precocious puberty it's a yeah it's a
disorder where people will have puberty
on set much earlier than they should oh
yeah i was reading about that but even
even for that uh if you look at the
people who have been treated with lupron
for that they as adults have severe
health issues yeah yeah crazy
all right liam says starting june 5th
i'll start work as a wildland
firefighter up in oregon i'll try to
still watch the show between the fires
keeping the nicotine addicted drunk
irish firefighter stereotype alive
well all right
steven says a nurse practitioner in
certain states can act as a medical
provider independent of an md
that is true
aether eater says hey crew check out the
ordeal of the bitter water numbers 5-13
in the bible reddit keeps referencing
this to dunk on conservatives yeah so we
were sort of talking about this before
the show
this was something in the old testament
which refers to um
a procedure for a woman was it was
basically practical was accused of
adultery it's only referenced once
and
most translations actually refer to it
as the woman becoming like infertile if
she's cheated on her husband or
something i think there might be
some that use the the phrase which can
indicate miscarriage but most
translations
refer to it as something more along the
lines of fertility yeah so that's not
really an honest argument this is from
the old it's ancient practice where if a
woman was thought to have cheated on her
husband they'd go to the priest the
priest would be like drink this water
that i put some dirt in or whatever and
if you cheated on your husband you're
gonna be cursed with miscarriages and
infertility and so she gets all stressed
if she cheated on her husband this is
where i think it comes from and so her
stress kills the baby well but no she's
not even pregnant i don't believe it
even references her being pregnant it
just says that it would make her unable
to have a child or baron some
translations say miscarry but the ones
i've read don't use that it basically
just refers to infertility and it's only
referenced once it's not exactly
something that's like delineated as a
common occurrence so it's not an honest
argument at all all right common sense
phishing says to matt walsh and sheamus
my friend's wife was six months pregnant
baby became cancerous not mom was
spreading to mother and baby was still
alive abortion was the only option to
save mom and baby not viable
now that that's an interesting case i've
never heard of something like that um i
haven't considered that specific
instance i believe you should still do
everything you can to save the life of a
child as i've mentioned earlier i'm not
sure what that would entail i mean it
just seems reasonable like this this a
story like this has to happen
we know there are biological issues with
some babies and yeah i don't know that
the answer is to directly do an abortion
i'm not sure what interventions could
take place to attempt to save the life
of a child i'm saying if those
interventions are possible they should
be carried out what if it's not possible
it's just like take the baby out the
baby dies but the mom lives yeah i think
you do everything you can to save the
child and the mother and if you can't if
again if the child dies the child does
die i i think the the issue is
that argument
is aligned with the medical exemption
the left talks about
but they act like conservatives don't
feel that way at all
because i don't think they actually talk
to conservatives like that that guardian
article from stephen marsh he mentions
that republicans are gonna there's gonna
be a fight
unrest and and rioting and stuff
potentially civil civil war over
abortion
but he's like republicans are gonna lose
anyway because banning abortion doesn't
stop abortion and i'm like i i think
your position sheamus was like so what
did you repeat that yeah he said that
banning abortion won't stop women from
having abortions i mean in certain
circumstances and ian and i were talking
about this earlier but basically anytime
you pass any kind of law there are going
to be people who break it that doesn't
mean a law doesn't need to exist in the
first place you were saying i think you
said to me before so what the state
shouldn't endorse it it should be
illegal yeah no i don't think i don't
think abortion should be legal no no all
right
adrian contreras says does anyone else
miss the 80s i do i don't remember the
80s yeah i wasn't there they were okay
it was a lot of big hair hair spray um
hot pants the music yeah a lot of hot
pants
you had to ride your bike together
leopard print what about what's going on
in the 80s dude that was weird what was
my favorite guns and roses era yeah my
favorite part
of the 80s cartoons cartoons okay
they're pretty safe you could just sit
down in front of the tv and get like you
know normal funny i mean they were
pretty crappy too looking back on them
but it was the cartoons and also the nes
it was the breakthrough of video games
really that altered my reality because i
had the atari in 82 and then we got a
nintendo in 85
which was just uh gob stomping
awesome and then we got a sega genesis
and you're like what is happening to
reality all of a sudden now and then you
start to see these photo realistic
things and you're able to manipulate
them i mean for a young child that was
incredible it's funny because the
genesis was before my time but we didn't
have like a video game system as uh kids
and so we got a sega genesis from a
garage sale oh my goodness that thing
was so much fun
all right
age of 1 says i d transitioned at 29
after realizing my transition was due to
trauma after the death of my fiance to
fentanyl i was on hormones two years and
now i may be infertile love the show god
saved me
wow
all right let's uh let's grab a couple
more let's see we got i don't want to
miss any of these from up here
oh you know what let's talk about
planned parenthood in the members only
because there's one that's very spicy
having to do with eugenics
so i'll uh we'll we'll we'll uh
we'll we'll talk about that in the
members only i think it's gonna be
interesting
and uh nikki says to eat local honey i
do it doesn't work it does not cure
allergies i don't everyone's always said
like are you taking local honey it's
like dude we have so much farm local
honey that's amazing that i love
doesn't do anything also i cut out the
sugar because
sugar's bad but uh honey i do have a
little bit of
all right
and uh we'll talk a little bit more
about republicans and the midterms
coming up and let's see uh
let's just try and grab one more here
big red says roe v wade is the slavery
issue of our time the 1857 supreme court
decision dred scott v ferguson and the
1973 roe v wade decision both rendered
people as property
interesting all right everybody if you
haven't done so already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
that will be published at 11 p.m you can
follow the show at tim cast irl you can
follow me at tim cast basically
everywhere alana do you want to shout
out anything oh yeah um i have a sub
stack where i talk about trans issues um
and d transition stuff uh it is the same
as my twitter handle just.stubstack.com
did you put my twitter handle in the
description okay so just take that type
it in substack there you go
my name is sheamus i run a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we're going
to be releasing a cartoon on thursday we
also just released one today i think you
guys will enjoy and also i got to say i
think this was a fantastic episode
it was great having you on man thank you
and for clarification i'm 43 years old
in solar age which means my body's been
around the sun 43 times in genetic age
you'd have to figure that one out on
your own how young is my body because
it's they're different sometimes a young
solar body may have rapid genetic aging
and vice versa i think because ian never
sees the sun i stay out of the sun a lot
i don't eat i cut sugar out like at age
28 i cut back on sugar
make a lot of internet videos so i fix
my posture like i watch myself doing
wrong so i try and rectify it on a daily
basis it's kind of crazy because uh you
know we've been i've been skating quite
a bit recently blading and uh you know
after one year progression i'm getting
we've got a seven foot ramp i'm like a
foot or two over the coping and i'm like
it's getting bigger and i'm looking back
at some of the people my age who used to
skate too who are just
they're just out of it dude i saw a
picture of you on instagram where you
got air man yeah that was awesome
i'm 36 i skate all the time
and it i i do i i don't know this is the
thing to me i remember being a teenager
skating and meeting skaters who were in
their 30s and they were like you know it
gets harder you got to stretch i do not
feel any different today than when i was
16. genetics will lift you up baby i i'm
not even kidding when i say that maybe
it's because we i take this biotrust
stuff i think there's something about
internet videos when you watch yourself
on video you maintain that that visage
like you stay that age almost
genetically your body's like adapting to
it and if other people watch it they
think that that's who you are if they
watch a video from eight years ago they
think that's you so they their
impression of you is that you're younger
so they treat you like you're younger i
don't know all i know is i look at a lot
of people who are like i'm too old to do
those things anymore and they look like
they're middle-aged and i'm just like
i'm doing the same stuff i've been doing
since i was a teenager yeah i'm feeling
anything i won't use the age as an
excuse not maybe maybe it's because i
never stopped exercising and i've
maintained better health i had periods
where i was like eating really bad like
i weighed like i think 200 pounds in
december and now i'm down to like 170
something
nice no sugar weird daily wire i was
like hey how high can you jump tim and
he was like dude you got massive air you
got must have like three feet vert just
standing still yeah probably is how high
up you get
that's nuts all right we got lady
pressing the buttons yeah i am pressing
the buttons and i was gonna say i was
out at the blader cup last weekend in la
and those guys are about tim's age or
older and they are all looking fine so
it turns out if you just continue doing
the things you did when you were younger
that will keep you young i really think
that's a ticket anyway you guys can
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlets we will see you all at
timcast.com for this member segment
it's probably going to be really dark
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
there
you